What is that a record for?
Consecutive ones.
20 some?
Yes.
We live campaigns.
Flip that sucker over.
She don't get in distraction.
Oh,
sorry.
See,
that's what I had jet already checked
in.
This motherfucker is right in the other
room.
He's got a texture.
Make sure you sort of loose.
Make sure we were.
We just got back from an epic El con in
the mountains.
We did.
That was.
Epic is the right word.
You know,
I think people throw around epic a
little loosely.
They do it this time.
Not this time now.
No,
man.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
First of all,
the place was incredible.
The mountains up there,
which is the scenery was just stunning.
Like everywhere you look,
your jaws dropped.
Like whoa.
He has amazing everything about it.
Yeah,
I mean but,
but especially the scenery,
the mountains that they live in there,
they're rugged,
they're beautiful.
And you know,
the quakers haven't even turned yet.
Normally it seems like by this time
they're at.
That's all yellow.
Like all those white trees.
Yeah.
The aspens.
Why?
Why do you call him quickies?
Why does the quaking aspens quaking?
Aspen?
I've never heard them called quickies
until this past weekend or this past
week.
Rather.
Everybody's calling quakers and like,
what are you guys talking about?
Yeah,
that's a photo that I took from up
there.
Fuck man.
Everywhere we look.
It was just like there was too many
moments with elk that I couldn't film
because it was just.
I was just so engrossed in the idea of
like getting it done and the hunting
aspect of it that I didn't want to pull
my phone out and be taken pictures in
five minutes.
I did the tourist.
Yeah,
I took a few here and there,
but there were so many moments that I'm
so glad that under armour filmed this
whole thing.
Yeah.
So we're going to have a film of it.
The.
It's going to be released online so
people are going to get a chance to
check out how just incredible and epic
and maybe just get a tiny sense of what
we talk about when we talk about how
amazing it is to do this.
Yeah,
and we had the right guys filming it
because,
you know,
there's all sorts of different levels
of,
especially hunting films.
I mean there's guys out there just with
a handicap,
you know,
just trying to do the best I can to
share their experience.
And then there's guys like mark womack
and his crew with sub seven that make
films.
I mean,
you know,
he's filling me.
Um,
there's an episode called Roy's Buck,
a whitetail hunting Colorado the time
episode time.
Yeah,
that one's amazing time.
That's really good.
Oregon el Con.
And so those are not just your typical,
what people might think of as a hunting
film.
Those were just,
you know,
or hunting video.
These are true films.
Well,
it's a short film and it,
it's really like almost like a mini
documentary of how you're trying to
balance your life and training and
running and competing these ultra
marathons and then also working a full
time job and then also going out and go
on it.
I mean it's,
it's,
uh,
it's really well done.
So those same guys filmed us.
Yeah,
man,
we got some epic footage.
Just epic.
Yeah.
And,
and like you hopefully gives
a glimpse for people that haven't
experienced at or aren't hunters.
Maybe just to see I'm at everything
that's involved in the hunt and you
know,
how powerful it is and,
and just to add the wild animals out
there interacting with each other and
then how we fit in that.
It's crazy.
It is.
It's one of those things that I really
think are words like people will be
intrigued by the words,
but I don't think we're ever going to be
able to put it in their head what we
experienced because there was one point
in time where Jamison,
Colton and I were together in the woods
and uh,
I just stopped and as we were walking
towards his elk that was screaming and
screaming,
alc all around us.
And you hear these cow elk that are
making it
and screaming is bugling screaming.
We call it screaming.
But there is,
it's a,
it's part of the mating ritual basically
of a male elk bugling in it.
We call it screaming because it's just
like,
it's like going,
there's a little higher,
a couple higher notes in there.
But yeah.
Well,
some of them are like that,
some of them have a growl to it,
starts deep,
it goes high,
usually comes back deep.
And then the grants,
we heard
the one bull that I wound up killing
that sounded like Jurassic Park.
And it was a crazy scene because jamison
and I'm Colton and I were talked into
Jamieson was the guy was filming at
Colton was the guide and me and were
tucked into this one small area,
this,
these trees that was at the edge of this
creek and we were watching these dose
and we saw three dose.
So we knew and there's a lesson in this.
I said,
Dale,
I said those cows,
sorry,
wrong terminology.
Um,
there's a lesson in this for regular
people for life and this is the lesson
in life because we saw these cows and we
snuck in and we were like,
wow,
there's got to be a bull here because
there's like three cows.
And we saw three
one more time a year.
There's no cows unattended.
So there was 30 cows,
the cows cap file and in.
And we were like,
where is this bowl?
Like where is he?
And all of a sudden out of the creek,
bottom steam coming out of his mouth are
away 60,
70 yards.
Some point,
like through the trees and couldn't end
up screwed.
The bugling is deafening.
It feels like at that,
at that distance.
So close.
So loud.
And he was just letting everybody know.
Yeah,
don't fuck up.
Yeah.
I mean it's like a grand entrance.
So this gives you chills,
doesn't it?
Oh yeah.
But this is the less.
Okay.
There was one cow.
He had 30 cows.
Yeah.
And one cows.
Like I didn't want to be here.
I'm tired of being number three.
There's always wanted this and she takes
off and he could not just be satisfied
with this.
Thirty nine.
I think he had more than 30.
It was so hard to count.
There were everywhere,
but he could not be satisfied with the
cows.
He left.
He's like,
no,
no.
Where are you going?
Baby?
And went chasing after her and when he
went chasing after her,
these other cows that were left behind
started going.
They make this noise like they want some
Dick.
And when that was happening,
this other bull behind us was like,
oh,
felt that bill.
I'm the man for you girls.
Yeah,
well what?
Fuck that dude.
I'm right here.
So he started screaming and then the
other bolts started screaming.
So he decided it's too much.
And so he takes all of his cows and he
moves them over the top of the hill.
When he moved him over the top of the
hill,
we went after him and when we went after
him,
he turned around because he thought we
were that other bull.
He heard you.
He heard us walking.
Yeah.
So there's the thinking here.
I'm sure he just thought it was the bull
coming hurt their sticks breaking in
footfalls and things like that.
Yeah.
And that's how he gone.
Um,
yeah.
So if he just let that girl go get out
of here baby.
So let's a lesson.
The lesson is you got to let things go
sometimes.
Oh,
is that a 30 cows and one of them takes
off?
Or you might take an arrow in the chest.
You might.
Yeah.
Let him go,
I'm going to jot that down.
And actually it's a very strong lesson.
It's a lesson for life.
Like sometimes you can't be greedy.
He got greedy and when we probably got
them anyway,
but he got greedy.
It's tough.
You know,
those things,
they only have one thing on their mind
and that's breeding,
you know,
so there is no,
uh,
29 is good enough,
you know,
if we're rough numbers,
but let that one go.
They're fighting for everything they
got,
you know,
and it's,
we did see bulls fighting,
um,
you know,
it's uh,
we see the,
the,
the big herd bulls posturing,
you know,
so there bugling they get Kinda swole up
sometimes if they're uh,
you know,
if there's a subordinate bowl,
they'll kind of walk a little sideways
to say see how big I am.
I mean,
is all of this is body language that
goes on with these elk,
but it's what they do.
That's all they care about right now.
When we were cutting the bull open,
he had cuts and holes all over his rib
cage and his ass,
like everywhere marks from fighting like
a couple of the skin.
You see all this like punctures.
Yup.
Their antlers are uh,
I mean,
and they're big and big solid muscle.
I'm eight,
900 pound animals.
Barely any fat living in the mountains
in.
And you know how tough those mountains
were to get around in their everyday
sleeping on dirt.
Tough,
strong and fighting and yeah,
they get beat up.
Yeah.
I mean sort of what a crazy existence to
that for one month out of the year,
everything goes haywire.
Everything's going to f your friends.
Are you now your enemies.
You're ready to fight to the death with
guys who were just hanging out with a
couple of weeks.
Summer.
All summer.
Yeah.
You weren't at the lake but you were
hanging out at the lake,
but you guys are eating grass.
We're just looking out for wolves,
but actually they don't have walls up
there.
Well,
they had a wolf came through real
recently.
Rather.
There's a lot of bears,
but they don't have a ton of predators,
which is one reason why the elk are
doing so well up there.
It was incredible.
I've never seen so many elk in one
place,
like you had told me about it,
but when you get there and you hear them
all screaming,
we heard 100 different elks screaming in
this one basin.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I mean it's a,
it's unlike anything I've ever heard.
And I've.
Elk hunted a lot of different places and
that's the,
you know,
if you.
And I said,
if you're an elk hunter,
I said one morning,
I think it was the morning that it was
snowing and we were in on bowls,
you know,
crazy red activity,
amazing footage.
I'm cold,
Wet El Camino and I said,
told Mark,
and the guy said,
if you're an ell connor,
this is as good as it gets.
I mean,
it's,
you couldn't,
couldn't be any better.
No,
it was.
The terrain was beautiful.
The weather was beautiful.
There was one time where we had snuck up
to this one bull and he was younger.
He was still a big bull,
but he was.
You wanted to shoot every of the ranch
where we were at.
They were really smart in how they
manage the wildlife.
Yeah,
and one of the things they do is you're
supposed to only kill an animal that's
over eight years old.
Eight years or older.
Yeah.
So that way they've had many,
many,
many years to breed.
They're really like,
they're in the later years of their
life.
Like how,
how long does an elk live in the wild?
This it's lucky.
They thought that the bull I killed last
year was 15,
but that's rare.
That's crazy to me.
At a 10 year old bull was old,
so they figured out eight.
Then it starts going downhill,
so it's,
it's been past its prime that's past its
prime and that's passed this breeding
prime.
So that's when you want to take it out.
Yeah.
Colton said that mine was between eight
and a half and nine and a half.
He didn't.
They're trying to get specific and I
guess they have to take the jaw and send
it to a biologist.
Yep.
Teeth were and things like that.
So the,
the estimate was eight and a half to
nine and a half years old.
It's an old bull.
It's an old bull,
but yeah,
the tank this up.
So that property,
it's about a quarter million acres,
250,000
acres and they figured there's almost
3000 elk,
you know,
and that's actually a little bit more
than optimum,
a carrying capacity for that amount of
property,
that many l.
So they'd like to get that number down a
little bit and just increase the habitat
and,
and the elk herd health.
But uh,
did they ever think about capturing some
of those.
I know the Rocky Mountain Elk Federation
does that.
Is it a rocky mountain elk foundation?
What does foundation they,
they capture them and then they'll
release them to places like Kentucky and
they've sort of reestablished like a
real herd there now.
So for people,
for people that don't know,
at one point in time elk were
essentially all over the United States.
But then Europeans came and then market
hunting came and of course we had rifles
and it's not we,
we didn't do it.
They're people,
people that are like us out of hippo.
Yeah.
But they,
the market hunters essentially almost
wiped out the elk and at the turn of the
century there are very few elg,
very few deer.
And then they had established some
protocols and some wildlife conservation
ideas in place in order to try to revive
them.
They've done an amazing job since then
and now kind of foundations like the
rocky mountain elk foundation.
What they've done is move elk into areas
where they had been extricated.
So they were.
They had been driven out of the area,
essentially extinct,
extinct in this one particular region.
And now they have healthy populations.
They're hunting.
Yeah,
I mean they got enough to where they can
manage them.
Pennsylvania has a lot of elk now.
Big Bulls there.
Yeah,
I've seen them on,
on,
on the Internet.
A lot of.
Yeah.
No.
And it's,
you know,
we talk about this every time about
hunters and conservation and the rocky
mountain elk foundation,
but those are the groups that have
fought to protect elk and elk habitat
and that's why they're doing so well.
But so I think,
in fact,
here's a gratuitous crotch shot.
Let me see that.
Oh,
that's a rocky mountain elk foundation.
Steps back a little bit so people could
see the glory.
That is your belt buckle.
That is my belt buckle.
Yeah.
So that they've done an amazing job.
And then obviously there's companies
that have other foundations that have
done an amazing job for waterfowl and
protecting wetlands.
And then for white tails,
I mean there's more white tail deer in
America today than the war when Columbus
came,
that's what most people hunt is,
is white tail too,
because they're in eastern southern us.
You now were elk are mostly out west,
but they are moving back east again.
But yeah,
most,
most hunters are white tail hunters and
uh,
those,
that animal's doing amazing.
Yeah.
I mean so amazing.
So that they actually have to hire
people to kill them in some places where
they get too close to urban environments
and they have a ton of car accidents.
There are some states,
and God,
I wish I could,
I don't know every state and in the bag
limits,
but uh,
I'm thinking Alabama or somewhere down
in there where he can kill a deer a day,
as many as you want.
There's no predators.
There's no winter so that these animals
aren't dying on their own.
So I mean we just don't have unlimited
habitat because humans take up space.
So down there at the back and limit is a
deer a day.
Wow.
And I don't know if it's Alabama,
so don't,
don't quote me on that,
but that's one of those states.
Yeah.
I think they have something like that
similar in some parts of Pennsylvania
and New Jersey where they're in the
suburban areas.
I was watching a television show about
it.
I think it was one of those reality
shows where they hired people to come in
to hunt in suburban neighborhoods.
Yeah.
I've,
I've seen something about that too.
She's not back.
Yeah.
Well,
I saw an episode of a show the other day
with t bone was doing that.
T boned.
Turner was shooting.
Uh,
I love Tivo and he's a great guy.
Yeah.
He's shooting deer in this backyard in
between an above ground swimming pool
and swing set.
He shot a deer.
Yeah.
It was a swing movie.
No,
because here's a good shot.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
He's,
yeah.
Time at.
That'd be kind of fun to.
Million car accidents happen every year.
Just in North America with deer.
Yeah.
I'm sure at 150 people die every year in
car accidents.
Wasn't there a guy that died in your
neighborhood?
Yeah,
a deer went through a windshield of a
van or something like that,
and a right in Eugene.
There.
Didn't like hit the car in front of it,
hit it,
and then it flew into his.
I don't know now.
I can't remember the.
Do you think that's what you told me?
Yeah,
but it happens a lot.
it does.
I mean it's,
that's the.
There's always that balance of a animal
numbers and habitat and where we live
and making it all work.
Yeah,
and that's where people get super
emotional.
People get very emotional about animals,
you know?
I mean,
what does this whoa buck deer crashes
through suv?
Wouldn't she'll drive or hurt?
Yeah,
that.
That's crazy.
He didn't even do that guy didn't die.
Apparently.
He just got hurt.
Yeah.
That is crazy.
That looks like a mule deer.
It's a big,
big deer.
Yeah.
Come flying through your windshield.
People get sued
promotional about this.
This is one of those subjects wherever,
whenever we're talking about hunting,
like there's one way that we normally
talk about it when it's just like you
and I or maybe some other hunters when
we talk about how great it is,
how much we love and how great the meat
is,
and then there's a way that you talk
about it in public where you have to
sort of temper that knowing that there's
a bunch of people that are listening
that are going to get very emotional
that are maybe anti hunters and some of
them where it gets really weird.
Also eat meat.
Yeah,
I got,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm a sucker.
I read the comments on social media and
it's like,
you tell me,
don't read them,
but I think you do too.
But anyway,
and there's just some people.
It's like I saw one today and I think
you mentioned that I was going to be on.
Somebody said something like Joe for his
whatever.
I can't remember it.
Intelligent or in tune or something.
You are,
I can't believe you hunt,
you know,
or whatever.
It's just like check that dude's
instagram for a cheeseburger.
Yeah.
I check to see if he's got a cat,
but he's feeding murdered animals too.
To me,
I think if you are in tune with actually
how the world and nature in,
in how we live and what we need it,
the more in tune you are,
the more accepting you are of hunting.
Not,
not the more you,
you slide it because it's how it works.
It's how it's how we survive.
It's,
you know,
life eats life and it's just like,
it seems weird for people to think that,
oh,
I'm,
I'm evolved past that and I'm smarter,
more intelligent and urine neanderthal.
It's just,
it's opposite really
well what they're trying to do and I
understand it and I appreciate it.
What they're trying to do is move past
the idea that we have to be cruel and
that we have to kill animals and that we
have to live off the suffering of other
living creatures in our survive.
So this is like the Vegan idea,
right?
So what they want to do is live off only
plants
and you know,
and not participate at all in any sort
of slaughter of animals or any sort of
cruelty.
And in theory,
it's a great idea.
It's a great idea because nobody wants
to be cruel,
vicious.
I don't like to be her.
I don't want.
My goal isn't to be cruel.
I don't like seeing animals suffer,
right?
That's the worst thing in my life is to
see an animal suffer,
which sounds very contradictory.
Coming from a guy who killed a lot of
animals,
a hundred percent true.
I mean I don't,
I don't enjoy it.
If the animal suffers,
I feel bad.
Right?
But if it's okay,
clean kill,
it's better than anything that animal's
going to get in the wild,
in the wild,
that animal's going to die either by
freezing to death or being torn apart by
predators because it's old or it's going
to get injured and it's going to get
torn apart.
Antler,
I found a dead bull last year that took
an hour in the neck from fighting and
who knows how long it took to bleed out.
You know,
maybe it broke its neck,
maybe it was paralyzed and it laid there
and it took days to die.
But a hunter and what I do,
the term I like to use is being
merciful.
I want to be ethical,
quick and merciful when I kill an animal
because that's a 100 percent the
opposite of how nature works.
Well,
this is one thing that you have
said to me in private when we've talked
about it,
you know,
we were saying that what you trained for
and what you strive for is so that in
that moment you can make the most
precise shot and killed that animal as
quickly and as ethically and as
efficiently as possible,
and that,
that sounds that's on your mind every
time you release an arrow
every time.
Yeah.
And yeah,
so I just think people.
I know it's hard to understand.
I get it.
If you haven't hunted and you haven't
been in the mountains and you haven't
seen how cruel nature can actually be,
it's,
it's hard to comprehend.
Yeah,
it is,
is,
and it's also the reason why human
beings are today,
are here today.
The reason why we survived is because of
hunting.
Does it mean that you can't be a
vegetarian,
can't go vegan or.
No?
It doesn't.
You can do whatever you want to do,
but the reason why human beings have
made it to the top of the food chain is
because we consumed animals.
It's one of the primary reasons that
biologists believe that our brains
evolved past that have lower primates.
We figured out fire,
we figured out how to cook meat and the
nutrients from that cookie meet along
with the complex problem solving issues
that come up and hunting and one of the
reasons why we evolve because to be
smarter and more clever than these
animals that are faster than you,
smell better than you here,
better than you see,
better than you,
stronger than you.
They have more endurance.
Knew these elk,
run up that mountain.
Like it's a joke.
I was huffing and puffing.
I mean I've been running a lot since we
did that.
Um,
your keep hammering five k last year and
I realized what a pussy and then the
times that we've hunted together too,
I've just been really out of breath and
even though I work out,
do another things,
I realized I have to run hills.
So there's no way around it.
So it helped me a lot.
That was very nice to see.
It was very nice to see a big difference
in my endurance now where I can keep up.
Whereas before it was like a huge
struggle because every day we were doing
10,
12 miles,
but these health go up there like
nothing.
It's nothing so for a human at one point
in our evolutionary past to figure out
how to beat these things at their own
game,
trick them and get meat from them and
survive and then develop strategies,
strategies for that and then teach other
people in their community these
strategies and this evolved and this is
the reason why you and I are talking
today on microphones that are powered by
electricity that in this room that's
shelter in this city,
this complex series of buildings that
we've built a lot to protect us from the
environment and from other animals.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's been quite a journey and the part
of that.
So yeah,
we have evolved.
Yes,
we've got better and we are.
That's why we're different than an elk
and other animals.
That's.
And we take advantage of that
superiority and we use it to kill them,
to eat them,
to hold them at home.
But I just,
for me,
it's,
you know,
if it was about the killing,
just killing,
I wouldn't bow hunting.
Bow Hunting is very hard.
Um,
I would rifle hunt if I just want to go
out there and kill something that would
be,
that's usually the most efficient way to
get it.
Kills you.
So maybe 10 times easier,
I don't know.
But with a bow I just know how difficult
it is.
And,
and you know,
you talked about the improvements you've
made.
He'd been bow hunting now for four years
and um,
I just wanted,
I do want to touch on,
um,
it's been awesome to see the dedication
you have to the craft of bowhunting.
It is not easy.
I mean,
I know people who don't hunt see it and
say,
oh,
you just enjoy killing animals out
there.
I just said if I,
if I just want to kill,
I'd,
I'd use a gun.
It's,
it is about the challenge about the
experience and it's not easy and the
improvements you've made in four years
and it's basically through obsession.
I mean,
to be great at anything,
you need to be slightly obsessed.
And you have been,
but that learning curve for hunting is
so steep is sometimes people,
you know,
because of how we've talked and you
know,
the,
the stories we've shared on social
media,
it looks intriguing.
It looks,
um,
I don't know,
I mean it's just,
it's powerful.
So people,
they want a piece of that.
They want to know what that feels like
to be ingrained in that world.
And you know,
we get messages,
Hey,
I want to get started in bowhunting and
part of me is going,
God,
I want you to.
But it's a long journey.
It is hard.
That's almost too much.
It's not too much.
I don't want to discourage anybody but
God,
it's tough.
I mean,
just good enough.
Listen,
I've been doing this for almost 30 years
now.
Nineteen 89.
I killed my first bull.
Elk is a spike bull.
And so since 1989,
so this is 29 years of bowhunting and I
go into this season just like I go into
every season and I wonder is this going
to be the season where I don't get any
kid?
I have no success because it could
happen.
It's that hard because I've killed
before and had success for all these
years.
Doesn't mean anything right now.
Doesn't mean anything to an animal that
I was pursuing it in Utah,
a big bull,
that big bulk of care.
Less about.
Oh,
you know,
oh,
he's had a lot of success over the years
means nothing,
you know,
and like,
so I always wonder is this gonna be the
year where I can't get it done?
And it completely changes your
relationship to your food because all
your meat that you're getting in your
house is coming from your success.
Bowhunting.
Yeah.
So when you are entering into a season
and you're wondering whether or not
you're going to get success,
you are literally worrying whether or
not you're going to be able to provide
for your family the way you have been.
And it's not like we're starving.
Right.
Okay.
So this is the way you've chosen to meet
though,
and this ethical,
humane,
wild way.
One of my family goes to the freezer and
opens it.
There's always elk meat in there.
Always.
That's what I do.
I make sure we have,
my family has meat to eat,
so when they go to the freezer and open
it and there's no elk meat,
that's not good.
I mean,
yeah,
we're not going to starve,
but that's what we're used to.
That's,
that's I've provided like that.
My family,
friends and family have called,
Hey,
you got any elk meat you could spare.
Got Any hamburger,
you know,
whatever.
Always.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Love to.
That's,
that's what I love to do.
So I don't want the.
I don't want him to face the prospect of
not having that.
Right.
Yeah.
I give away a lot of it.
I'm constantly giving it to Brian Cowen.
Yeah.
Brian.
And to get back on the horse,
he hasn't had any success haunting in a
couple of years.
So he mooches off me.
Did he?
He's killed then.
Yeah.
He's got a few deer.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
He's never shot a bow before.
Um,
but he's rifle hunted.
I figured that's why he was so ripped
his from all that,
that a lean meat meat,
lean protein because he's,
he is a beautiful man.
He's beautiful.
Um,
yeah.
He wants to get into bow hunting,
but it's another one of those things
like,
you know,
you say you do,
but do you really,
you know,
because if you do,
it's going to take it all in and you
can't go halfway.
No.
And,
and there's another thing that people
love to say,
you know that meat is terrible for you
and you're going to get cancer and heart
attacks and diabetes.
People keep repeating that.
Stop saying it because it's not true.
You're wrong.
I know you like to say that because it
sounds good and it sounds like a really
good argument for people that eat meat.
It's absolutely untrue.
And if you go back and look at the real
studies,
the only thing that they've shown is
there's a connection between cancer and
processed food.
There is a connection between
preservatives,
nitrites
and a lot of the things that we use to
make processed meat.
So if you're talking about things like
hot dogs and processed meats and you
know,
kind of like beef sticks,
you might get at the gas station.
Yeah,
eat enough of those and your body's
going to revolt.
It's not good for you,
but wild game meat is some of the most
nutritious and healthy things that you
can put in your body and that's just a
fact and so people that keep putting
these comments on campaigns,
his instagram page and occasionally on
mine and all these different,
they always want to say this,
Kay k nutrients are good luck with your
heart.
It's not true in every study that has
shown that it is true is bullshit.
They've all been debunked by actual
science.
If you look at the real people that are
putting together these documentaries
that show that meat causes diabetes,
they are fools and it's not true.
It's been widely debunked.
What they are as proselytizing vegans,
they're vegans who want everyone to
become vegan so they are distorting
truth and making documentaries that have
no basis in actual reality and science
and if you just google like it was the
most recent one.
Those guys did the hell yeah.
What the health.
Google what the health debunked and
there's a ton of scientists that have no
stake in the game.
They're not like from the meat industry.
They're just people that have seen,
the doctors have reviewed it.
There's people that have seen the actual
facts and seeing this documentary and
go,
this is nonsense.
And so people regurgitate that stuff all
the time.
I just want to tell people like,
go,
just do some research,
read some of the actual studies.
Here's,
here's what's bad for you.
A sedentary lifestyle,
sedentary lifestyles,
terrible for you,
sitting in your office chair,
one sitting in a cubicle,
eating too much bad for you.
High carbohydrate diets,
bad for getting too fat,
bad for you,
drinking a lot of alcohol,
bad for drinking,
sugary sodas,
bad for you.
All those things are way worse for you
than an elk stake.
Way Worse.
So if you're eating any of those things
or doing any of those things and you
say,
good luck with your hood,
took fuck off because you don't know
what you're talking about.
Yeah,
it's true.
And I,
uh,
since we're central talking about one
thing that I get,
I think we have to be careful on is a
slamming,
I guess the,
uh,
the beef industry because I'm not,
we're not trying to do that.
You know,
people always say,
you know,
there's cattle ranchers out there that
work hard,
that it right.
And you know,
there is factory farming which people I
feel like almost,
I've been guilty of it maybe thrown
around factory farming,
almost like a Vegan will throw around
and good luck with that heart attack.
And they're most,
there's a lot of ranches that do it
right that have the cattle out there,
free ranging and the only time that
they're there in a small enclosure is
when they are killed.
Slaughter.
Yeah.
Brought to slaughter.
So I mean,
um,
you know,
I buy,
I buy steaks still occasionally from my
buddy at e three.
Uh,
there's plenty of places that have,
I don't know if you're gonna look at
ethical beef production.
There's a lot of places that do it.
I agree.
And the same thing can be said with
chicken and same thing you'd say with
poultry,
Turkey,
there's a lot of free range and it's
more of an emphasis.
I think that's one of the reasons why
people become more and more interested
in hunting today.
They're doing well,
but people are more concerned with the
ethics behind how their food is raised.
You know,
there's a lot of farm to table
restaurants that are opening up which
are really amazing.
You can go and you can,
you know I'm and there's a place near me
and you get these eggs and they're dark
yolks,
like a dark orange yolk at this
restaurant and they have like grass fed
beef that tastes healthy.
It tastes really good and that's the
stuff we're supposed to be eating.
We've gotten into this crazy situation
as human beings where we're getting food
that is in a lot of ways tasteless
because it's been engineered to last
forever on a shelf.
We've gotten this meat that's gotten
super fat because they're pumping them
up with antibiotics and feeding them
grain until they just become these fat,
unhealthy things that are in no way
resemble a wild creature.
Well,
we had a steak last night at the
airport.
No,
I've tastewise is like,
I could barely taste it.
Yeah.
It was nothing.
Not much to it.
Yeah,
and I think there was also probably the
way it was cooked,
but what was really weird is the
difference in the connection with that.
Right?
Like when you sit down and you cook an
elk steak,
you remember where you were when you
shot that,
you remember how hard it was to get to
that elk.
You remember the stock,
you remember maybe made me several blown
stocks where the wind shifted on you and
the elk spooked and took off and how
difficult it is and the intense success.
And that's another thing that people
don't like.
The idea of the happiness that comes
with success when you kill something,
but
it's hard to understand,
I think.
Yeah.
But it's.
Yeah,
I mean it's an achievement and it has
not like,
oh,
we're selling,
we murdered something.
So we're celebrating,
but it's,
it's so hard.
We talked about the difficulty.
Um,
you have achieved something of,
of great difficulty with that animal's
dead.
And then your skinning it,
you're cutting the meat off.
I mean,
you know,
I took out the tenderloins of,
uh,
of the bull I killed,
you know,
and smelled it and made sure the meat is
always just making sure that,
that is the fruit of the labor,
right there is that meat,
so you just,
you're holding a big slab of steak and
like you said,
you remember everything,
but most of what I'm thinking of there
is how clean it is,
how pure it is,
does it smell good,
smells perfect.
And that's just kind of the process.
It goes in the meat bag,
it goes on my back,
it comes off the mountain,
it goes in the cooler,
it goes to the process or it gets cut
and frozen
wrapped and then then I cook it.
That's a lot of,
I mean,
a lot of steps.
We go to the airport,
we say,
uh,
yeah,
can I get the Sirloin?
It's it.
Yeah.
That's it.
And that's how most people do it.
Yeah.
And that's a weird place that we've
gotten into as human beings.
Hunters are judged negatively for having
just that whole emotional thing and all
the,
the meaning and the feeling.
And the,
and the connection to it in,
and we're judged negatively for that.
The but the person who sits down and
says,
I'll take the sirloin.
That's good.
Uh,
good to go.
It's like,
it should be opposite.
It should,
but you know what it is too.
It's like the building is faceless,
right?
Okay.
The restaurant is faceless.
The supermarket is faceless.
You have no idea who did the actual
killing of the cow.
When you go to the woods and you come
out with an elk steak and you kill it
and you're wearing a rocky mountain elk
foundation belt buckle.
And your campaigns like people can look
to you.
Well there I found one right there like
you are.
And your connection to death.
Meanwhile,
if someone was outside protesting you
like they found out we're doing this
podcast near like you son of a bitch.
Yeah,
we're,
we're the ones who put up the petition.
We want to get you banned from under
armor.
You're a terrible person.
You're a trophy hunter.
You're out there killing animals.
All around them is dead animals.
Every gas station is filled with beef
sticks.
Every restaurant is filled with dead
animals.
Every supermarket is filled with dead
In this area where we're at,
there are 100 places that you can walk
to inside of three minutes that have
dead animals in them.
Yeah,
but they're.
They'd be protesting here,
testing here.
You because you're the face.
And meanwhile that's what's so back ass
words about it and it's because we're
doing the right way.
You're doing not saying you have to do
it that way,
but if you wanted to have the most.
This is weird word,
spiritual connection to your food.
It's,
there's no this,
there's nothing else I've ever
experienced that's even remotely close.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
and there's I guess to some people,
some people are getting it,
you know,
there's some people that would be
protest.
I hear it wouldn't matter what
justification you had.
They are never going to see it and
that's fine because we're all different.
We all have different passions,
so that group of people,
whatever.
But there's a people in the middle that
we have,
they have heard and they have thought
about it and they have realized that
does make it actually make sense.
And those are the people that want to
know what it'd be like to be a provider
for themselves to go to go into the
mountains and,
and become loaded,
loaded out with a,
you know,
a pack full of meat.
And so those are the people I guess
we're talking to.
We're never going to get the extreme.
People know.
I mean,
and that's always going to be the case
with all arguments.
There's always going to be radical
people on all sides,
you know.
And I think,
uh,
our job as human beings communicating to
human beings is
to try to relay our own experiences as
clear and as honest as possible.
And that's why I was trying to look at
it from the other point of view.
I always try to look at it from what
people that I think are good people that
become vegans because they're good
people because they want to have no
cruelty.
And I think they just have a perspective
that I don't share and that perspective
is I've actually been involved in.
I've gone through the ritual of the
hunting,
we've gone through the trials and
tribulations of hiking many,
many miles and trying to find these
things and trying to figure out the wind
and.
And it hasn't all been success.
No,
it's a lot of failure.
It's a lot of failure.
It's more successful lately than ever.
But that's just because I've worked
harder than ever.
And then it be more and more dedication,
more time being obsessed.
More time practicing.
I practice every day.
Yeah.
I'm shooting every day.
It's a,
you know,
people see the success,
they see the pictures.
If it's something they want to hate me,
they hate.
I'm sitting there with the dead elk.
But hunting is such a rollercoaster.
It's like everything is magnified.
The success is magnified because it's so
hard.
The failure is magnified because it
hurts so bad because you've worked so
hard.
I mean,
I just,
I,
it took me.
I started,
like I said,
in 1989,
it took me to 1996 to kill my first six
point bull elk in the wilderness and,
and it would have been,
we wouldn't even look at it on this last
time.
It would have been like,
ah,
there's a little bowl.
I mean,
but when I,
when I got that six point bullel I felt
so proud I'd finally achieved.
I mean,
that's,
that's a bull on this buckle right here
is a six point and I thought I finally
did it,
but in between there had been so many
disappointments and devastations and in
the wilderness.
I remember one time I had been in there
by myself.
I'm thinking like day eight as in this
dry creek bed and here comes these cows
come across,
here comes this big bowl and I don't
know how big he was.
He was pretty big for their three,
2130,
which is a scoring number.
It would,
which is calculating the length of the
antlers of the antlers.
Right?
So it would have been still slightly
smaller than the Bulls we just killed.
And he came across there and I'm on my
knees and I shoot and uh,
I,
I hit,
if you hit him in the shoulder back
then,
um,
the bose weren't as efficient as they
are now,
but if you hit him in the shoulder
blade,
it went in about,
I would say an inch inch and a half
Arrow hit his shoulder blades stopped
and basically fell out and he went
running off and I went up and picked up
my Arrow and there's blood on the
broadhead and to them,
you know,
something like that is they might have a
sore shoulder for a little while.
They take antlers and the guts and neck
and all the time.
So they heal up there.
They're amazing.
So that was nothing centrally,
nothing more than a flesh wound.
But I remember sitting there looking at
my Arrow,
looking at little bit of blood on my
broadhead and I mean eyes welling up
with tears because eight days just
there.
But working all year towards that moment
and having that opportunity at 43 yards
and being inches off because inches
further to the right back would have
been doubled.
Long Dead Bull.
Biggest bull ever.
All the hard work paid off to being
devastated.
So people see the success some 20 years
later or whatever it's been.
They don't to be,
to feel as disappointed as I was to,
to wonder if all the work was worth it
to hurt that bad.
They don't see that.
But that's why hunting is so powerful.
That's why hunting has changed my life
because it's so difficult.
And because there's those ups and downs
and you know,
we try,
we do a better job of sharing the
complete journey now than back in the
day.
You just,
you know,
just be like,
hey,
killed his bull.
That's it.
You know,
you'd go to the archery pro shop,
you put your picture up of the bullies
you killed.
And that was it.
Now we're a little more in tune.
I see all sorts of people on social
media now.
And they,
they,
they showed the picture of their bowl
and they get down,
you read the caption,
it's about,
you know,
providing for their family and,
and pure protein in their freezer.
So we were doing a better job of
explaining it.
But still,
until you've been there,
it's really hard to grasp what it all
means.
No,
I don't
to anybody's going to.
I don't think it's possible.
It's also,
it's something more,
it's a,
it's a discipline,
but it's something more like sometimes
people call bowhunting a sport and I
always kind of cringe.
Yeah,
I don't like that either because I think
it's not a word for it now.
I don't think there's a comparative
word.
I think it's bow hunting.
I think it is what it is because I
don't,
I don't.
It's a lifestyle is what I say.
You have to be immersed in the lifestyle
to really understand it.
A sport makes it seem like,
you know,
keeping score well,
to me it's a lot like Jujitsu in that
way too.
Where if you talk to people who train in
Jujitsu a lot,
they understand how difficult it is and
they understand the struggle and they
understand that in that struggle.
Like all struggles every day.
I think people need struggle.
I think it's very important.
Yeah,
like you.
You get better not just at the Jujitsu
or not just at the bowhunting.
You get better at being a person and I
feel better today after this trip in
Utah than I felt before I left.
Not that I felt bad before I left.
I felt great,
but I feel energized.
I feel energized because the experience,
a fear,
analgesia energized because of the
struggle.
I feel energized because of how
difficult it was to hike those mountains
up and down and chasing those elk around
and,
and having things blow out and getting
back to the,
to the lodge and being so tired that you
could just barely eat your food.
And then I'm passing out almost like out
of as I'm done eating and then I crashed
and the alarm goes off at 5:00
in the morning and then you're out there
in the dark.
Doing it again and then have success so
to to understand that you can push
through things and you can get better
and you can practice things and you can
get better and that applies to
everything in life.
It does.
It's a discipline,
but it's discipline like almost no other
because it's not just a discipline.
It's a discipline that also sustains you
and your family and it's a discipline
that involves like real critical moments
of life and death.
Like when I was drawn back on that bowl
and I'm looking at this bull through a
very small window where I could shoot
between these two trees 32 yards away
and Colton,
who was the guy paused,
this bully made a cow sound like being
like right where that bull needed to
stop.
Like the bulb walked in.
He,
he called it stopped and that critical
moment where you have to make a perfect
shot in a split second and intensity
intensity roxane.
It's like nothing else.
Yeah,
it's,
it's end to do it and to do it
successfully and then have that elk
dying seconds and have that elk wander
off 20 yards.
Like seeing it bleed out of both sides,
knowing this is it,
and this is probably.
No,
not probably,
definitely.
Unless he falls off a cliff.
This is the cleanest,
fastest death this thing is ever going
to have.
Yeah.
No,
and I'm.
And I'm going to eat it tonight.
Yeah.
It's,
I don't know.
There's so much reverence in the moment.
I what I like and we talked about this
film and in and capturing it and
hopefully with the message we can convey
with a film,
but you did a great job after that shot
of really just a,
I guess verbalizing how you felt in and,
and kind of everything you just said,
but more authentic because it was,
it was.
You were there in the bowl,
was laying there dead and uh,
it's um,
I don't know.
It's intense.
I wish there's a way people could get
it.
I think these kind of conversations help
a little bit and I know for people
listening,
there's some people that go,
oh,
you guys are redundant.
You're just defending hunting,
hunting again.
So boring next.
Anytime
it's your guy with the baseball hat on
sound.
I almost didn't wear a hat today,
but why baseball hats?
They don't like baseball.
I got it.
I've been coughing forever.
I'm like,
Huh?
What about,
what about baseball hats?
They don't like baseball hats.
What do you.
Where's this coming from?
I saw it on your comments.
You got to stop reading those.
I think mostly Kinda say like berets.
I'm a painter of the arts one tee shirt
I wanted to make up.
Now I'm not going to say it.
Going to say my,
uh,
my tee shirt ideas sometimes aren't the
greatest hitter.
Hilarious when no one's around.
They can be on money.
The one about rain gear is awesome.
Oh my God.
So I tried to,
I try to be positive.
I mean,
I.
Yeah.
Anyway,
except when you're just being funny.
See,
that's like,
that's what I do for a living.
Like when people say,
well that's pretty negative.
Well it's not really because I don't
mean it,
you know,
like my friends will say some of the
rudest shit about me and I'll laugh my
ass off because I need to just paint me
a little bit.
You've made it a little bit,
but that's what makes it funny.
He didn't mean that at all.
If there was no truth to it at all,
it'd be no humor
to it at all.
Had I wanted to touch on this a,
you know,
we talk about the struggle and the,
uh,
the hardship.
I'm Adam Green tree,
our friend,
you know,
he,
he had a in a lot of people here have
followed along on his journey and what
would happen.
Yeah.
In his journey will be.
So he hunted three different states over
the course of about three weeks and,
uh,
by himself,
by himself solo in the back country with
a tiny little tent.
Yeah.
He hunted Colorado.
Then he went to Montana,
then he ended up killing a bull on
Idaho.
If you look on the surface of it,
if you didn't understand,
you think,
oh,
he undid three states and he killed a
five point bull.
Wow.
That was,
you know,
that's a lot of effort for that.
But to him and to people who,
who embrace struggle,
it's not just the,
a five point bull died.
That was a journey and that was the end
of the journey and they were success and
there was,
you know,
there was tons of failure along the way.
Well,
the best part about it was it.
He documented the entire thing on
instagram.
He did it on his instagram story and I
let people know I put up a bunch of
posts about it and one of the posts that
sent his followers skyrocketing was him
holding a pistol and then in the
distance he took a photo of this crazy
bastard in the moment there's a fucking
giant grizzly standing on its hind legs.
Looking at him from it looked like no
more than 50,
60 yards away and he's holding up a
pistol that I said that it's one of the
most,
like you could see it there.
Yeah.
That looks like it may be at the most
probably 100 videos.
So I think it stands out.
Oh,
is this video?
Yeah,
she comes with that.
Look,
that gun looks like it's 200 years old.
I don't think it is.
I think it's just out of focus how it's
got,
but yeah,
I mean that,
you know,
that's a phone video,
so I mean it's way closer than the
looks.
It keeps standing up to try to figure
out where he is,
what he's doing,
and in a moment like that
she keeps standing up.
Shoot,
I'm may lie that his head office,
she comes for me one more time.
I just can't imagine what it'd be like.
They're welling out there for 20 plus
days by yourself.
A moment like that is,
you know,
we're pretty used to being around
people.
I mean,
if something happened here,
I know you do whatever you could.
Jamie would do whatever he could to help
you know,
if we needed help with in that nobody's
coming your bike 100 percent.
He's by himself and that,
those types of experiences,
where else are you going to get that?
So he's in,
he's in the mountains.
There's a bear that the bears just doing
what barriers do right?
And,
but that.
And he's immersed himself into that
world and that's all part of this whole
process,
that whole journey.
But that's what intrigued everybody does
following along is because that's as
real as it gets.
Yeah.
You know,
and he surviving and we talked about,
you know,
in our house we got back tired.
We were able to go to be dry and
everything else in that intent,
you're getting in a tent if you were wet
when you got into the tent,
you're going to be wet in the morning.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean it's uh,
it's,
it's uncomfortable,
it's uncomfortable.
And I know that's what I grew up doing
because I had no other option that has.
I mean I could hunt Oregon for $25 on an
elk tag and hunt public land and that's
all I did for decades because I was the
only option I have.
And that is,
that is difficult.
And like I said,
you question why you're doing it.
And people would say no,
I'd kill like a.
If I saw five point bowl,
like what Adam killed,
I'd kill it and be happy.
And people say you don't need to work
that hard to kill an elk.
You know,
you could kill that bull off off a
gravel road and a truck camp,
but to me that's not what it was about.
It was about the,
the whole journey in the wilderness and
surviving and,
and navigating and problem solving and
yeah,
maybe it wasn't the biggest bull in the
world,
but that's just one piece of the puzzle.
Yeah,
there isn't.
There's a
difference between,
and I have done this a few times between
camping and staying a lodge standard
lodges nicer.
Oh yeah.
We were,
we were in Utah.
We would go back to the lodge and it
was,
you know,
you and me and our buddy Ben O'brian was
there and was lots of laughs and we're
having a good time.
We'd all eat dinner together and just
shoot the shit.
When you're in the woods and you're
camping,
you're still in the woods.
There's no like with the largest
civilization,
there's electricity,
there's hot water.
You can take a shower when you're in the
woods,
you stay in the woods when you camp,
you wake up,
you're in the woods,
you're,
it's a more immersive experience.
And then there's the next level,
which is what Adam did in the woods by
himself for manny,
manny,
days before he had success.
And then there's video of him after he
shot that elk 20 whatever days in when,
you know,
he's like,
it's finally over.
It's finally over.
It's like,
that guy just went on a vision quest,
you know,
so much respect for that,
I mean,
he is so tough.
And he's um,
bowhunting means,
I don't know if you,
if you tried to explain to explain what,
how,
what does one mean to you?
You couldn't do it with words for
somebody like him,
you know?
And,
and I,
I would lock myself in there.
It's like bawling defines who I am,
who he is.
But uh,
you know,
it's,
it's.
I know I've done seminars before and
I've asked people,
okay,
if there's a 100 or 200 people there,
how many people stayed out in the woods,
in the mountains by themself for one
night.
Her never,
hardly anybody.
I mean,
how many people do you know that have
stayed out in the woods by themselves
for night?
I just know a few because I know
hunter's like remy new and green tree
and a few other folks,
right?
So most people,
they don't like to be by themselves and
they want to feel safe.
So for Adam to do that for three weeks,
that says something because hardly
anybody ever does it.
Right.
You know,
and so he did that.
Loved it.
I think he loved it.
His video said he loved it.
He didn't always love it,
but no,
I,
I can't speak for him,
but I can speak for myself and know that
you don't always love it.
Um,
there's times where I,
I would question,
like I said,
what am I doing?
Is this worth it?
But you'd fight through that and then,
and then you come out stronger and be
ready for the next challenge and
hopefully paid off.
I think any experience in nature is good
for people.
I think we spent entirely too much time
and cities entirely too much time
indoors and buildings and artificial
lighting and all that stuff.
I think any experience in nature at all
is good for you.
It's just good to be grounded and
literally grounded,
like to feel the ground and to
understand that this is,
this is the wild world,
this is the real world because the other
thing is this out thing that we've sort
of concocted as human beings,
but the more time you spend in there,
the more it reveals itself to you and
there's a weird empty loneliness to true
wilderness.
Like when you're at the top of a
mountain and you don't have any cell
signal and you don't see a building
anywhere as far as the eye can see.
You don't see there's no.
We're nowhere near city when we're out
there.
When you sit up there and you look out
and you hear a coyote howl and you see
an eagle fly overhead and you know,
you hear an elk bugle,
you just.
It's just,
there's nothing like it.
Now.
It's the real wild.
I mean these things,
they don't.
They don't know you're a real thing.
They don't care.
They care.
If you get close to them,
they'll run away.
But what they're there to do is what
they've been doing for thousands.
Yeah,
and that's it set.
It's so different.
You talk about how we got to lax last
night and I'm just walking around going
and I don't know,
100 percent feel this way,
but I'm like,
I told,
told you,
I'm like,
I hate people just there was so many
because we went from no people and
that's,
it's so enriching.
And so,
I dunno what I keep saying,
powerful.
I don't know word,
but is it all the time by Stag stag.
Powerful Joe Rogan.
Um,
but in the mountains it's A.
I dunno,
it's so simple.
Life is so simple.
It's like it isn't,
it isn't.
Right.
Because it's super complicated.
Like to survive out there you have to
have a lot of things work in your favor.
Yeah.
But it's simple because either you
survive or you don't.
Yeah.
But it's not because it's either you
kill the bull or you don't,
or you eat berries,
automate a lot of berries.
Yeah.
So,
I mean it's a,
that's where I,
like,
I like about that.
It's simple.
There's no,
you know,
there's no different social classes of
people.
There's no
very important.
Right?
Yeah,
that's,
there's a,
there's a thing that happens out there
where you're clearly defined by your
ability to perform under pressure.
Only if you're,
if you go out there and you're some
famous rock star or something like that.
Here's some,
you know,
some guy who lives in a giant mansion
and flies around and private jet and you
own an island,
but you choke when you're going to shoot
a ball and you shoot it in the Dick and
everybody knows you're a loser.
You're a loser.
Yeah.
Isn't that amazing?
Is A,
there's a leveling.
There's out there.
It's like the people who get respect
hunters get re.
I mean if you,
uh,
um,
you know,
if you can navigate,
if you can see elk,
if you can,
uh,
read blood.
If your blood trailing you can,
you,
you got woodsmen ship,
you can unravel a blood trail.
You can start a fire.
You're here.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter about how much money
you have or who you are.
If you can't do any of that stuff while
you're
your lower.
To me,
it was incredibly important to be able
to perform during crunch time because I
wanted the respect of the people that
also do it.
I wanted to get that was very important
to be able to in that moment and I spent
so much time thinking about it,
going over podcasts and all that.
Joel Turner stuff about target panic and
about the closed loop,
an open loop mind systems and how your
brain functions pressure and thinking
about all these different things.
A lot of thought to this might sound
ridiculous to somebody who has that
shot.
A bow that like what?
No,
you just pull back and shoot,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It's when you look at a 900 pound forest
horse was spears grown out of its head
and screaming and there's one shot.
You have one opportunity and by the way,
you only have one tag and if you wound
an animal,
it's over.
Yeah.
If you.
If you just shot in the ankle and it
starts bleeding,
guess what?
Your tags over the money that you spent
is done.
You failed and that thing lives to be,
you know,
lives to be an elk and lives another
day,
another day,
and you,
uh,
you go back disappointed and you have to
start from scratch and rebuild yourself.
And that's good too.
The failure in the feeling of failure is
the real motivator.
That's what,
what makes you run more miles,
more arrows worked hard to think about
it.
Think your way through this thing.
And to me that,
that leveling of the social classes is
very important.
You know,
it's something that I think Jujitsu does
as well.
Um,
there's another parallel in that because
even comedy does that as well because if
you're not funny,
people don't laugh and they don't like
you,
you know,
you have to be able to do the thing and
sometimes the thing doesn't work out and
then you feel like fucking terrible,
you know?
And that leveling of the classes that
happens in bowhunting is a,
is it's hard as I keep saying,
it's hard to describe because it really
is.
I think anything that's very difficult
to do.
You find out more about yourself and
when you find out more about yourself,
you have two options.
Either you can go into denial or ignore
it or you know,
fade back or you could face it and
struggle more and get better and really
work at it and that's where I think
bowhunting shares a lot of,
a lot of its aspects with other
difficult but yet important things in
life that become.
They become a vehicle for developing
your human potential.
Yeah,
and that running is like that too.
We'll look what it's done for you.
I mean your,
your passion and obsession with elk
hunting is what led you to being this
crazy ultra marathon runner.
I mean that's really what started it
all.
I wanted to be better in the mountains.
Yeah,
better at it.
I never really understood until I hunted
with you because when you would run up
the top of the fucking hill when the elk
would go over the top and you'd run up
the hill and I would just speech,
struggling to go a quarter of the way
and I'd have to take a break and then to
go a little further and take a break and
you already are or up there and you
weren't even out of breath.
And then I thought about it.
I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
I get this.
No,
like this.
There's a lot to this.
Yeah,
yeah.
That.
And that's um,
you know,
you talked about it is,
it's crazy to bowhunting has done what
it's done.
I've been on Joe Rogan
nine times,
Jamie nine times and you know,
I don't for me personally because I just
feel like I'm okay about.
I'm decent at bowhunting and it's just
the fact that I was even here one time
seems surreal.
But what I,
I just,
I want to thank,
I don't know,
I was thinking about this earlier is
because of bowhunting.
My people,
I know people will say,
because I,
again,
I read the comments,
but don't read the comments.
They'll talk about that a,
Oh,
it must be nice for Joe to be able to
hunt wherever.
I mean where we were,
it was amazing.
Is like,
that's where we all kind of just where I
feel like I've had to work my whole life
to get to,
to dream,
to killing bulls on public land,
to,
to starting with the spike bowl to 30
years of this and it's a dream and it's
like I,
I will never take for granted what it
means to where we were hunting in Utah.
But it seems crazy to think that you
grew up in Massachusetts,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
You had the whole different journey.
You weren't some kid bowhunting,
but you were a comedian and a fighter
and a whatever.
But bowhunting brought us together and
we shared this,
this life changing time and Utah from
completely opposite paths.
And so whether that's,
um,
you know,
you,
you took your path to get to the best
outcome in the world.
I took my path.
It doesn't matter.
We were hunters.
They're sharing the mountain and taking
on the challenge together and that's
what bowhunting does is it eliminates,
you know,
you're here in la.
It eliminates everything and we're the
same.
Yeah,
all very difficult pursuits,
but we're limited in their bullshit and
it's a,
it's,
there's not very many things I can do
that we named a few of them,
but it's just like when you think about
it like that,
it seems unreal
real,
but it also sort of really clearly
defines why this discipline is so
important to you and I
[inaudible] well and it's,
I don't know.
I think it's.
And hopefully we've opened the eyes of
others to see that I don't know,
to,
to want that same type of experience.
You know,
you might not be the same.
It might not.
Not Everybody's going to get to where we
hunted in Utah because it's great
public land hunt.
I mean,
I was listening to Brian Barney's
podcast,
the Eastman elevated podcasts where he
took a couple of buddies when I was
actually cutting up meat today.
I was listening to this,
took a couple of buddies with him on a
public land hunt in Montana and they got
into some elk and they seemed like they
had an amazing time.
They got rained out,
Mrs.
Same sort of thing.
It's an amazing adventure,
you know?
It's available in a lot of different
forms to a lot of people and there's a
lot of people that go,
Oh,
you know,
this is bullshit.
You know,
joe gets to do this and chose low key
and this and I think it's Hashtag
bullshit.
Hashtag bullshit.
Yeah.
Guess what?
I'm lucky.
I've always been lucky.
I don't know what to do.
You want me to be unlucky?
I can't.
I'm just lucky.
I mean,
maybe I'll be unlucky off.
That's also part of luck.
Part of luck is you have to.
It's what is that,
that phrase like luck is when
opportunity meets preparation.
You know,
that's what some people say.
It's that,
but it's also luck.
You know,
there's,
there's people that are luckier than
you,
you know,
and,
but by the way,
there's people that are way fucking
luckier than me.
You don't think Justin Bieber's lucky
than me,
that little cunt.
He's never been poor in his life.
He's worth 100 million bucks and he's
like 20 years old.
He probably has no comment.
His body,
he's probably everyday just drained.
He probably just has to eat raw eggs all
day just to try to just try to keep up.
Yeah,
stay hydrated.
Justin.
Stay hydrated,
kid.
Yeah,
we're counting on you.
I mean that little fuckers way more
lucky at Cameron.
There's always literally there's always
going to be people that are luckier than
you and some of it is luck and some of
it is courage.
Some of it is putting your ass out
there.
Some of it is trying things.
One of the things that I always like to
tell people that I think you should do
is do shit that's difficult.
It's very important to struggle and it
doesn't mean bowhunting.
I liked yoga class for the same reason I
go in there,
it's me and a bunch of housewives and
they're kicking ass more than I am.
I mean,
I watched these ladies and I watched
their mental strength and fortitude.
While they're grueling their way through
this 100,
four degree temperature holding these
poses,
I'm watching the sweat poor off their
face and they're not complaining,
they're just in there grinding,
you know,
and that's,
that's fucking so important in this
life.
This life doesn't have enough of that.
There's not enough struggle.
You don't get to know yourself without
struggle.
You don't get to know your boundaries
unless you push them.
You don't get to know who you are
really,
unless you're tested and there's too
many weak pussies pussies out there.
And so those are the people that drive
me crazy because everything you just
said is so true.
But there are so many people that would
rather stand on the sidelines and say,
Oh,
must be nice to be able to blah,
blah,
blah.
Shut up.
Yeah,
it is nice.
It's also,
you worked your ass off.
Come follow me,
bitch.
Come,
come do what I do.
Yeah,
good luck.
Those are the people.
When you were talking about running was
so you were involved in,
someone was behind you and they were
like running right on your,
your your tail and you're like,
oh,
let's see how this works out for you.
Like it's not.
It's not even a cocky thing.
It's like there's no way a regular
person is going to keep up with you in a
race.
It's just not going to happen.
Let's see how this works out and that's
just because they're not getting up at
5:00
in the morning.
I follow your instagram,
your your fucking running before work.
Right now you're running a marathon a
day for people that don't know you run.
They're literally preparing right now.
Why?
Cam is in the middle of bow hunting
season.
He takes a little bit of time off of
this fucking insane preparation,
which is good because it allows his body
to heal,
but he's going to compete in the Moab in
October.
That is 238 fucking miles.
It's a straight rate.
It's not 238 miles over the course of a
month.
No,
no,
no.
It's 238 miles from beginning.
Ready go to the races.
Over 238 miles.
It'll take what?
Three days?
I don't know.
We don't know.
Seven,
eight hours to do two.
Oh,
five,
right foot.
200.
And did he ran 205 fucking miles in 78
hours.
So shut your mouth.
Moves.
Printers.
There's levels this life,
there's levels to this.
This dedication to discipline,
to drive,
to focus,
to obsession.
There's levels to it,
and if you're sitting on the sidelines
will most be noise.
Guess what,
Pussy you're not doing this.
This is my lab here.
God Damn.
Look at this horrendous fucking terrain.
They're running on a mountain.
GS.
As quite.
Look,
look at this video for people who are
listening only I urge you to please go.
Jamie,
what does the video official trailer for
the Moab?
Two Hundred Moab.
200.
And I love that.
They call it 200.
Meanwhile it's 238.
Like,
no,
you're not pissy.
He got out of the 38 miles.
No,
but the terrain is fucking insane.
It's insane.
So that,
that.
That's my lab,
I've never run in Moab,
which is the draw for me,
you know.
Um,
I've been in the mountains a lot.
I haven't been.
What's going to be tough about this race
specifically is you see how there's no
shade.
So that's what we call that as it's
exposed,
you're exposed the whole time to the sun
and that,
that looks like candace right there.
Who's a race director.
She's running this in this trailer right
here.
Um,
so this was her brain child basically.
And uh,
she must be a savage.
She is,
she's a total stud.
I mean,
she's,
she's running a bunch of,
done really well in hundred mile ultras.
This terrain is fucking magnificent,
right?
So being exposed like that,
that just sucks everything out of you.
The son can just sap you and,
uh,
keeping your,
your skin covered as well as you can,
keeping hydrated,
keeping fueled up.
That's just a,
the name of the game,
you know,
what shoes will you be running on?
Um,
it'll be,
you know,
my under armour fat tires is what I'll
be running in because that much pounding
for that long.
The cushion for my body is important and
imperative basically.
And the fat tires,
the underarmour fat tires.
How much different are they than the
under armour fat tire hunting boots
because I know they have those two that
the souls are similar.
Similar as much cushioning.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you get a good amount of cushioning
and also a good amount of traction,
right?
Because basically the fat tires,
the way they're,
the reason why they're named that way is
because they essentially,
the bottoms of them are like a bmx rode
mountain bike,
mountain bike tire.
They had a mountain bike tire called fat
tire
and I think Michelin made it so Michelin
makes these,
these same souls for the under armour
shoes.
And that's what I generally trained in
because running a marathon a day as you.
That's what I was trying to do before
season season is Kinda,
um,
hopefully it's context.
Yeah.
Hunting season is his interrupted my
training.
But I,
I sorta had this,
this game plan where this would be the
time I'd recover.
So,
um,
my whole training slogan is a train hard
hunt.
Easy meaning that I want my training to
be harder than any hunt I could go on.
And so the hunt seems like it's easier,
easier than my training and that's,
that's kind of what's been going on.
The.
I mean the Utah country was tough.
It was high,
it was steep.
There's lots of walking,
but it was easier than running a
marathon a day.
So I felt I felt good.
There's the fat tire.
Yes.
So those shoes also will allow you to
run over elect sharp rocks and things
and it'll absorb that.
So it'll give your feet some protection.
Obviously this is an incredibly
difficult pursuit that you're about.
Yeah,
there they are.
There.
That was a photo back home.
But uh,
um,
yeah,
those shoes,
they've worked well for me.
Uh,
they're great.
They've kept my body healthy with all
the pounding.
You know,
people always ask about knees and hips.
Anything else?
You know,
I've run a lot in those minimalist
shoes,
but I don't,
I don't think you could.
I mean,
maybe you could.
Does anybody run these fucking ultra
marathons in minimalist shoes now?
You can just can't write.
Not that I've ever seen,
it just seems like it's too much,
but there's,
you know,
everybody's different,
right?
There probably is somebody who can
because they're 20 some years old and
they feel great and therefore whatever.
Maybe it's been doing it in those shoes
for a long time.
Their body mechanics are different than
mine,
you know,
they're lighter than me,
so yeah,
maybe they could.
So it's,
I never loved anybody in like,
Oh,
you can't do this.
You can do that.
They might be able to.
I can't.
That's another thing too about you is
that you're lifting a lot of weights too
because you need it for you.
You also need strength for hunting.
You need strength to pull the bow back.
You need strength to be able to pack out
the meat.
There's a lot of other aspects to like
what you need out of your body that
maybe the regular ultra marathon runner
doesn't.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
I've tried to.
I've tweaked my training over the years.
There was a time where all I was doing
was running 20 miles a day,
not lifting,
hardly eating,
and I was down to 157 pounds,
so now I try to,
I that didn't work that great for
hunting because I'm trying to pack meat
and in the mountains.
You guys felt tired?
Yeah,
I just didn't feel.
I just didn't feel at my best.
I could still kill.
I could still get,
get the job done,
but I felt like I wasn't at my best.
So now I feel like what I do now,
this is a small shirt,
so it's like,
don't,
don't be tricked by that.
I'm filling out the shirt
that's a size small size,
small Ontario.
That's because it jed
fucking judd.
I'm grateful.
Dead Shirt on.
I'm like,
Hey,
you got any.
You got any size mediums for me?
And he's like,
oh,
they're all gone.
So here I am.
I stuck with the smallest am I look like
a more jack that I really am pretty
jacked.
Dude.
I've worked out with you.
Stop.
But it's just unusual for someone who,
an endurance athlete who does these
long,
you know,
200 plus mile races to be packing a lot
of muscle.
Yeah.
It's one of the reasons why whenever
someone would talk about UFC fighters
not being able to make the weight or,
you know,
whatever,
complaints they have about not being
able to make weight.
I'm like my friend Cam literally you
make your body eat itself to drop down.
You were at 180 plus pounds before you
started.
And then when you went to run the big
foot,
200 you had do,
you were,
you were burning 3000 calories and
eating 2000 or a thousand calorie
deficit.
So if it was,
if I was burning for 83,
so are far as burning three 82,
something like that.
So I try to to,
uh,
be at a deficit,
a thousand calories every day.
And your body was just eating itself.
Yeah.
So when I went into that race,
I was 160 165 and I had been in
[inaudible] 84.
So I lost 19 pounds of just that calorie
deficit and just the key with those is
being light,
you know,
the lighter you are,
the best ultra runners are generally 140
pounds,
maybe six foot,
you know,
I mean just light and that's just to be
efficient.
The longer legs is more efficient.
Is that why it's better to be six foot
and really skinny?
Nah,
I've just,
I mean maybe I'm just kind of
generalizing,
but a,
that seems like those are good runners
are about that size.
Is that like Goggins David Goggins
would.
I think he's a little bigger.
He,
he's,
he's more muscular than most and he's.
But he's a freak.
He's a mental freak.
He's a freak.
I mean,
so,
so inspiring.
You ever listen to him talk about the
time,
mental toughness?
I listened to a.
He did a podcast with a rich roll.
Oh,
there's another guy I love.
Yeah.
And so I listened to him on that
podcast.
I've listened to it like three times
because anytime you think that,
oh,
you got a harder,
you can't do this,
you can't do that.
Come on.
There's levels come on,
there's levels he is,
and that's another one.
You can't lump everybody into the same
category and say,
well,
if David Goggins did this,
you can't do what Dave and David Goggins
if you want to become David Goggins.
Good fucking luck.
I don't stop when I'm tired.
I stop when I'm done.
Yeah,
he's,
he's intense.
He has another saying that I think of
all the time when I'm running that most
people quit at 40 percent.
Yeah,
I know.
And that's,
that's 100 percent true.
And uh,
I found that,
you know,
there's lots of times will I want to
quit.
And I think if I click on that picture
right there,
Jamie,
the where he sees abs,
they were just,
you had just had your cursor.
Yeah.
That's a Jack Dude for someone who runs
hundreds of miles and he did,
you know,
he was over 300 pounds twice in his
life.
Yeah.
Fat and lethargic.
And
he wanted to be a navy seal.
He's over $300 there.
They said he had to lose something like
100 or 80 pounds and just a number of
months.
And he did.
Yeah.
And didn't he also break a world record
in suffering is the true test of life?
No.
He,
he broke the world record in whole.
Yeah.
How many pull ups did he do?
4,000.
30 in how many minutes?
Seventeen hours.
Yeah.
He fuck.
But he did it and I've seen some video
in 17 hours.
What,
uh,
his shoulders look like.
What's the inside?
It's just all scar tissue holding that
thing together.
Let's see if they could find a video,
Jamie,
because I've seen a video of him doing
David completed 2,588
pull ups in five hundred sixty six cents
for a total of four point six pull ups.
Preset 1000 pull ups in two hours.
Forty eight minutes and 2000 pull ups
and 3034 minutes.
But at 13 point five hours in,
he felt something in his wrist snap and
was not able to go on an x ray at 10:30.
Confirmed a partial tear in his forearm.
Wow.
So that's,
that's when he fell.
He failed twice to break the record and
then ended up getting it.
Wow,
so you can get to a video because
there's a video of him doing it and it's
just savage.
He would do like a set a forearm apart.
He would do sets of five,
so he'd do five then dropped down,
take a break for a sec,
do five more.
And he kept doing that is what I.
When I saw that,
well you know,
that's that Pavle taught celine's idea
of a strength training.
I think I've told you that he believes
that you should only look if you can do
sets of more than five,
that what you're doing is bodybuilding.
You should do five with very clean
technique,
take a big break and then do another
five and then just keep doing it for
long periods of time.
Like ideally maybe some people don't
have the time to do those kinds of
workouts,
but he believes you should do like with
five to 10 minute rest in between
workouts sets and just do a bunch of
sets like that.
And I've been doing that for awhile now
and I feel less sore,
less fatigue.
It can do it more often and I just feel
like he make better progress that way.
Yeah.
I think there's something to it.
I think we have a lot of like meathead
ideas in our head of what you're
supposed to do as far as working out as
far as you know,
going to failure all the time with heavy
weights.
That's the only way to get strong.
I don't necessarily think that's true.
No,
and,
but I will say everyone's different.
Yeah.
But this the thing where I should have a
caveat.
If you're a power lifter,
I should shut the fuck up because if
you're off,
all you're trying to do is like massive
amounts of weight.
Like a lot of these guys do.
Well then you know,
they're,
they're gonna push their body quite a
bit more than I am.
Yeah.
I see guys all the time do things that
most people would say you should never
do.
And they have a lot of success.
You know?
I mean,
nobody's going to say you should run a
marathon everyday during your say that's
a good way to get injured and that's too
much in your body.
You're not,
you're not getting the most out of your
body.
Nobody's like,
when I lift,
I try to do tons of reps,
you know,
at least 20 reps per set.
But you're doing lighter weights.
Yeah.
You're not trying to go to failure with
heavy weights,
trying to go to failure with everything.
And so if 20 doesn't get it then I'll do
40.
You know?
So it's been a unit.
You're not trying to go to failure with
like three.
Oh,
five for Ben.
No,
no,
no.
See that's what I'm talking about.
And that's where people get hurt.
No,
but so people need to find what works
for them basically.
I mean there's all,
there's a lot of schools of thought on
like,
okay,
for the average person do this and that
works for most people,
but it's not going to work for David
Goggins or depends on your goals and
your body and your ability and what
you're trying to accomplish and your
dedication.
What is the standard routine for someone
who's trying to run an ultra marathon?
So if you're running a marathon a day,
is that,
is that a normal thing?
Like what do they,
what do you guys communicate with each
other?
Because it was only a handful of yet.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Have you talked to those people are just
doing what you think you should do?
Yeah,
I have never talked to anybody about
training.
What?
No,
you don't talk to any of those people.
So you just go out there and do your
shit.
Yeah.
What a freak.
Now I,
I,
there's guys,
you know,
there's guys that train,
I'm trying to think of.
Oh Jim Walmsley and he,
uh,
he's a amazing.
I mean I have zero ability compared to
this guy.
I think he's about 26.
He lives down in Arizona and he's been
trying to break the uh,
western states.
100 ultra marathon record for two years
now.
Last year he was on pace to break it.
He was like at a mile 90 and I don't
know,
20,
40 some minutes ahead.
Of course,
record pace took the wrong turn because
this is in the mountains,
it starts at squaw valley and ends and
Auburn took her the wrong trail and went
off course and ended up finishing 20th,
you know,
because he had to backtrack and it's
mentally broke him.
So he was going to come back this year
better than ever and his training and
he'd be like running 140 mile weeks,
so 20 miles a day,
a 100,
150 mile weeks or some guys that have
that do more than that.
But anyway,
this year he came in and he went again.
Went ahead.
A was ahead of course record pace and an
ultra marathon term or maybe a running
term in general as he blew up at mile 76
I think.
And had to drop.
She went to hard.
Yup.
Wow.
So.
And he's,
he's doing record.
What,
what is he trying to break the record
for?
That is like 14 something.
Fourteen hours now.
What is the,
is that
there's a guy who just broke the ultra
marathon record for a flat,
like a flat 100.
Not In the mountains like you do,
but a flat one and he's on an off like a
high fat diet.
Right?
Isn't he on Jamie?
We talked about that guy recently.
He's on a ketogenic diet and he broke
the was on the track is a 24 hour record
and he ran a 100 and I can't remember
how many,
how many miles it was.
Yeah,
but you felt like maybe for the
mountains you might want to alter your
diet.
Like maybe that's not the for me.
Yeah.
I mean have you ever tried to like a fat
based diet or a Ketogenic Diet?
I don't know what you call it,
but my buddies I've,
I lived with back home,
Nick Hammon and Eric Mccormack there.
They both do bodybuilding competitions,
strengths,
but exactly outlaw strength.
I love that Guy Dude and nick the
trainer dude.
Yeah.
And so to get lean for those shows,
basically you cut the carbs out and this
is many proteins in Greens as you want
so you can have salad and steak.
So I've done that and I've got down to
six percent body fat just to see what it
was like and that's essentially what
that is.
And do you feel like you perform any
differently?
Terrible,
terrible,
terrible.
It felt terrible about it.
Oh,
no strength,
no endurance.
Because no carbs.
Hmm.
So zero carbs like.
No,
no,
no.
Like just vegetables for the know on a
low carb day it'd be 50 to 75 grams of
carbs.
Did you ever get your blood sugar check
to see if your key to genic and.
No.
No I don't.
It's interesting because I feel I feel
like this.
It's very important to talk about that.
Everybody's body is different.
Yeah.
You know who's a great proponent of this
is robb wolf and one of the really
interesting things about rob was a
scientist and a very,
very smart guy when it comes to
nutrition and health rights,
about books,
about Paleo diets,
but one of the more interesting things
that rob does is he will eat the same
thing as his wife and they'll both to
test themselves,
test their blood and he'll do it on
video and his wife is consistently more
adaptive than he is like they're eating
the same thing like it should,
but but his body for whatever reason,
doesn't perform as well.
Processing carbohydrates as hers does
and I say,
and she didn't stay in a ketogenic state
and eat far more carbs than he can.
Okay.
I'm gonna let you in on a,
on a little secret.
Oh,
I don't even know what the hell
ketogenic means.
I've heard Quito,
Quito,
jet.
I'm like,
okay,
well what is it?
Okay.
In a state of Ketosis,
your body burns off fat instead of
carbohydrates and you have to have an
adaptation period where your body goes
from carbohydrates to fats as a fuel
source and your brain uses ketones in
your body,
uses ketones for fuel instead of
carbohydrates and glucose.
Is there an advantage?
Yes,
and I would suggest that anybody who's
interested in this,
um,
go to my podcast with Dom D'agostino,
it
was four months ago maybe,
or Tim Ferriss podcast with Dom
D'agostino is also an excellent
resource.
And there's advantages in terms of the,
uh,
your body's ability to fight off disease
and cancer.
Cognitive ability improves and we'd be
smarter,
Bro.
I doubt it.
But could I be better?
What's that?
Nine 94.
Not episode nine slash 90 for this
podcast.
And Yeah,
you'd Bowhunt Austin minute.
Well,
I just think you need a lot of fat
though.
And maybe with your diet you're not
taking in enough fat.
Like you have to have a lot of fat
animal fat.
That's the Cahtos yeah,
that's one thing.
Coconut oil told me the other day
because I was just like,
we lifted and I'm so weak because I was
running so much.
Right.
And so we did it.
We did a just a few quick calculations
and if you run a marathon a day at my
way it was.
And then just living because just
living,
you're going to burn 1700 calories a day
or me then plus the 3,300
or something that I'd burn when running
a marathon.
So it was like 5,000
calories and as eating three row,
2000 deficit,
um,
that's too much.
Yeah.
So he said I needed to just ramp up the
fats,
you know,
so it started hammering nuts,
Avocados,
things like that.
And um,
I actually did.
I was feeling better.
We lifted again and I felt better.
So I think that's the big part of the
key to genic died that people get wrong
is that ketogenic diet is primarily fats
and then you have an adequate amount of
protein dependent upon how much activity
you do.
You obviously do a lot of activity.
You would need more protein than most.
And I think you would also probably need
more actual carbohydrates in most.
Yeah.
And still stay in Ketosis.
I think if that's probably one of the
reasons why you were so tired and you
felt weak.
But also I think this thing that you're
doing most people are just not going to
do not going to burn three and eat too.
They're just not going to do print print
for getting ready for 200 mile race.
Yeah.
So it's,
I'm trying to figure it out as I go.
So you don't talk to this is what freaks
me out.
So you don't talk to other ultra
marathon people.
I hate people like me.
I do know,
I like,
I like a lot of people,
man.
I like um,
most people fall short of your
expectations.
Yeah,
I like winners.
I like strong people.
I like people who don't judge other
people.
I like,
you don't like me,
then I judge everybody know,
judge you,
I just Jamie,
no fucking shirt he's wearing now.
I mean I just don't like complainers.
Right?
And so there's not a,
there's not a lot of people who,
I'm,
I dunno,
I want to respect people.
Well,
I think that with the level of output
that you are putting out and the amount
of focus and dedication to these things,
the amount of obsession to performing at
a 200 plus mile race,
a whiny bullshit that you hear is just
so much more magnified than what I hear.
Yeah.
You know,
like if I hear whiny stuff for my seven
year old,
it becomes funny because I start going
or you're going to be okay.
Are you going to be okay?
And she's like,
stop it Daddy.
I go,
what are you going to do?
You're going to beat me up.
I go,
come on punk.
And she'll get off the couch and she'll
kick me and then we'll have a little fun
and play around together.
But she's savvy them.
Yeah.
If I hear whiny stuff from a grown
adult,
I'm like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
We live in a world where if it's cold
out,
you press a button and it gets warm.
And we live in a world where water.
The thing that keeps us alive that
people struggled to find in most of the
free world comes out of a fucking.
You have a lever and you're sinking
every sink in every bathroom.
We could just drink fresh water.
Glug,
glug,
glug.
Think what are you complaining about?
Fuck.
Are you complaining about them?
Planning about because Joe Rogan and can
go elk hunting here and you can hashtag
bullshit.
Yeah,
I mean,
so that's,
that's the kind of stuff that's been
nice.
I pretty much don't listen to anybody
except people who I know share my
mindset about not just on running or
whatever,
just about in life.
Well,
that's why I'm just confused as to why
you don't have a group of people that
you're close to that are also ultra
marathon runners.
You can compare notes with.
There's not a lot of people that do
those.
I mean,
yeah,
ultra.
My brother does ultras.
My brother is a stud.
So how odd he,
he,
uh,
some genetics in that family.
Huh?
Was Your Dad is a big time athlete to
actually my dad.
I have no talent compared to my dad.
So my dad was an ultra,
just not ultra marathon,
ultra freak.
He was just an athletic freak.
Um,
so,
but my,
my brother,
um,
he does a lot of miles.
We don't really even,
we just kind of do our own thing.
We know what it takes.
You got to pound out miles.
You Dad was trying to compete in the
Olympics,
right?
I think he had Olympic potential.
So what happened is,
uh,
he was a high jumper and a long jumper
and uh,
you know,
I,
I just,
I took,
my daughter was doing pole vaulting last
year in and they kinda hurt.
My Dad was a awesome pole vaulter at
South Eugene high school.
He was the first athlete inducted in the
hall of fame and uh,
they did that right before he died.
But uh,
in the south Eugene Hall of Famer,
that high school there in Eugene is,
um,
anyway,
so he,
uh,
these coaches at where my daughter was
doing pole vaulting,
they said,
you know,
after a few different practices they had
heard about her and me and her grandpa
was.
And so he's,
he comes up and he's like,
he goes,
was your,
uh,
your dad Bob Haynes?
And I'm like,
yeah.
And he goes,
uh,
yeah,
he was a,
he was a legend around here because they
went to high school together and now
they've been coaching rather.
And he just said that everybody knew Bob
Hanes and he could do things nobody else
could do and what it is,
I think where he would have his success
was in high jump and he could high jump
six four.
And what he did at that time was called
the western roll.
And so you just kinda roll over the bar.
And then he'd competed against Dick
Fosbury and he invented the Fosbury
flop.
So you'd go with your back to the bar
and then kick your legs over.
And so they would compete.
And my dad got earned a scholarship at,
at Oregon for gymnastics.
And then Oregon State for track when
they had track and um,
ended up dropping out of both of both
schools.
And,
um,
they said that he would,
he get high jumped six floor during the
western roll.
And they said,
well,
we're going to teach you that the
Fosbury flop and we should build to add
eight to 12 inches onto your jumps.
So that'll put them at seven feet and
that would have been up there with Dick
Fosbury and um,
and Dick.
So my dad ended up dropping out of
school or in whatever happened in I was
born.
And then my brother was born,
you know,
how life gets in the way.
And then meanwhile a Dick Fosbury went
to the Olympics and won the gold medal.
So it's just who knows what would
happen.
But the fact is,
he was an amazing athlete.
You know,
what,
if you just want to say just in high
school,
that's fine.
But,
uh,
you know,
he was a d one athlete in two different
sports.
So I didn't,
I never had that.
I don't have that potential.
What I have is just a hard work ethic.
And um,
that's what I've translate.
So I,
without the Olympic or without the
athletic talents,
maybe that he has,
I might have the words work ethic that
might match a talent.
And that's what I've used to do.
Ultras because basically that's just
been tough.
I mean I think,
I think it was just grinding and,
and put in miles and training and then
getting where everybody else wants to
quit and pushing through in the races.
So you don't.
I have a few friends like I know.
What was the woman's name that runs
candice?
Candice Bergen friends with her.
And he and your friends with your
brother obviously who also runs ultra?
Yeah.
Do you have other friends that do this
that you like email with or text
message?
No.
One is that normal?
No,
I mean ultra runners in general are,
are a fucking Weirdos,
Weirdos,
but I'm independent.
Right.
You know,
you have to be,
you can't rely on anybody,
you know,
you can't see who's going to tell me to
go run a marathon every day.
Right.
Everybody's gonna say that's too much.
You don't need to do that.
So it's like ultra runners are
independent.
How long have they been doing ultra
marathons?
Well,
the western states 100 started in 1974.
Whoa.
And what was the old times like?
What was like a good time back then to
do 100?
What they seeing the western states
started as a horse race and they still
do it.
It's courses yet the [inaudible] Cup and
so it's,
it's the same course with the same goal
is covered 100 miles in under 24 hours.
So if you do that,
you get the buckle and it says 100 miles
one day and that's like the gold metal
full for an ultra runner.
So they have that same thing for horses.
And Gordon Ainslie was,
he was in the horse race,
his horse came up lame and he said,
well I'm going to finish it on my own,
on his,
on his feet,
Jesus.
And so he did that and that's where
western states endurance race or run
began because it's like,
well let's just,
let's just do this on our feet.
What a fucking animal.
That guy.
Yeah.
And he still competes in the western
states right now.
He's.
How old is he?
But he can.
He can't break 20 week.
He can't even break.
So you can get a buckle 100 miles one
day if you break 24,
if you break 30 you get a cookie and you
get a buckle up.
Just is western states endurance run.
But if you don't break 30 you get
nothing.
So he's tried for I think when,
when I ran it in 2010.
God what was he 60 some.
Probably he at the 30 mile cutoff.
He was at like the 90 some mile cutoff.
So the 30 hour cutoff.
Yeah.
And so he was at the 97 mile at 30
hours.
So that it,
he was done.
Right.
But anyway,
so he tries every year and he gets a
long way from being 70.
I think he's over 70 now.
Wow.
Yeah.
But anyway,
so he started that and that was in the
seventies.
And then nowadays there's more races.
Every state,
pretty a lot of states out west have
hunter,
you know,
that's Kinda the ultra scene is in the
mountains out here as they do the ones
the mountains will.
That western states is in the mountains
and mountains that starts at squaw
valley.
So it was a lot of elevation,
there's a lot of that race has 41,000
feet of elevation change.
Wow.
So you're gaining 18,000
and you're losing 21 overall.
The course goes from squaw valley down
to Auburn.
But in the course of that it's up and
down,
up and down,
up and down.
And so you're gaining 18 or over the
course of 100 miles and losing 21 wow.
Or something like that.
It's 41,000
different and even running down still
difficult because you're decelerating.
You have to stop your momentum.
So for us,
a 70 plus year old guy to do that,
that's one thing about.
So you start at that race and they
always say once you get into the canyon
there,
um,
don't bomb downhill too fast,
which is sort of early in the race as
before mile 50.
But if you bombed down hill too fast in
the canyons,
you'll blow your quads out.
You won't be finishing the race.
So you pound your quads too much.
So you got to,
even though you could go fast,
downhill,
you gotta take it easy because you've
got to preserve your quads.
So your quads are getting
used and the decelerating.
Yep.
Interesting.
Yeah,
they're getting pounded.
So,
and,
and where we are now.
And candace,
Bert with her,
she has um,
thing is.
So she's got bigfoot Tahoe,
Moab.
Yeah.
She's got three to hundreds.
So now her thing is too high.
Two hundreds of the or wait 200 years of
the new 100 or whatever.
But anyway,
it's the next level is $200.
Well,
yeah,
she calls up to hundreds.
I'm like 2:38.
Yeah.
You gotta say to 38 district rounding.
I don't know.
That's silly.
Rounding.
She should call the 2:38.
The Moab to 38 is what it should be
called.
Jesus.
Candice.
And it's.
Hey,
it's her race.
Hate numbers.
It's her radar.
It is Arctic Antarctic ice marathon.
Jesus Christ.
First of all,
it's only 100 k.
that's what I could do that on his
hands.
Yeah.
60 slash 62 miles.
Yeah,
I know.
That'd be fun.
Yeah,
I guess.
I'm stupid.
What are,
you don't see anything but white,
at least Moab.
You're looking at epic landscape.
It's a challenge though,
you know,
so it's,
it's all about the,
a new challenge.
Now,
how many people enter into mobe or big
foot?
200.
How many people?
Um,
this year when I did it last year,
there was 74.
I think this year there's over 100.
And how many people finish when I did
it?
Forty seven.
Finished imodium.
Press.
Yeah.
Most of people.
I mean if you sign up for $200,
it's not like you're doing that on a
whim.
I mean,
you're prepared a 100 mile on a whim
recently.
Yeah.
God,
that was terrible.
Yeah.
But the idea that you could do a 100
mile race on a whim,
it was the most painful pain.
Painful pain is most painful pain I've
ever felt.
Was that why you started going to a
marathon a day afterwards?
Yeah,
I mean I just knew that was in a,
that was the ledger Brisa 24 hour run
and that was in June.
And I'm like,
God,
I'm behind on my schedule,
on my training.
I gotta just,
I gotta grind out a big one so I'm like,
I'm going to do it.
So you decided to grind out a big one
just to boost your training,
just to get you over the hump myself up.
And so,
uh,
why,
how does that benefit you?
Just mentally?
Or does it do it physically as well?
He asked me questions like that.
It probably doesn't,
but in the time were you thinking like,
this'll get me over the hump and it'll
get in shape just like Derek's going to
do it?
Yeah.
During that race I was turning into,
remember I said I,
most people are weak pussies you became
a week because he definitely.
So uh,
I was in that race and a feeling
miserable.
So I had,
I was like,
well,
okay,
maybe I'll quit at 30 miles.
Thirty miles is still good run,
right?
I hadn't run 30 miles by June,
so I'm like,
okay,
that's,
I'm just going to say this is just a
training day tomorrow I'll go home,
rest up and maybe I'll do another long
run.
And that will be good back back because
that's what you need for those,
for those.
The 200 mile races is Moshe running is
your beat to shit.
So I mean you,
you know,
you gotta be able to push through.
So the back to back training days are
key.
So at 30 miles I was about at six hours
and I'm like God,
maybe I feel,
I feel awful,
but maybe I'll quit at 50 so I got to 50
miles and I'm like God,
okay,
maybe I'll run 12 hours.
So at 12 hours as at 61 miles and a is
at night and night the race starts at
nine in the morning.
Nine at night I was at 61 miles at
feeling awful.
But I'm like Oh my God,
I'm going to be such a pussy if I quit
because my not because there's anything
wrong with running a 12 hour race in
[inaudible] 61 miles.
That's awesome.
That's,
that's,
that's hard.
Super hard.
But for me,
my goal was 24 hours.
I signed up for the 24 hour race,
so 12 hours isn't 24.
So I'm like,
well,
I got 12 hours to get 39 miles,
I just did 61 miles in 12 hours so I
could just milk it out and still get my
hundred,
which was my goal,
24 hours,
100 miles.
So I thought,
well I got,
I got 12 hours to get 39 miles and uh,
it was the worst 12 hours,
but it,
I barely got it.
I mean it was.
So I did 61 and 12 and then it took me,
took me 12 to get the 39,
but I got 100 miles done and it was,
you know,
wasn't trained up,
wasn't ready,
but uh,
had all these reasons and I was
thinking,
I was running,
thinking of all these excuses I could
say,
and I can say that I cramped up and you
know,
this is a good example of why you
shouldn't,
what not,
you know,
push your body passes limit.
And I could just be all,
get all these Kudos for being smart and
in everybody just say it's okay,
you did great.
But I would know,
I would know that I pushed out.
So I kept going and didn't you run 13
miles the next day?
Yeah,
because you have to.
So,
so my,
my whole thing was see this
going 200 mile distance and an ultra
marathon may be healthier than stopping
at $100.
Holy Shit.
How does that make sense?
Scroll up.
The pacing is different for the people
that studied that.
We're going just 100 that were going
slower,
which led to lots of different
interesting scroll.
I could do that.
The reason 200 milers,
uh,
aren't as fatigued as the hundred mile
group was due to pacing the tour desk.
Yawns how do you say that?
G E a n t s toward dig.
Gaulle's runner's average three point
four miles per hour.
During the course.
While the 100 mile runners took a faster
four point five miles per hour pace.
Rich Roll was saying that was it.
When he runs ultra marathons,
like when he was training that one of
keys was never
get his heart rate over 140 beats per
minute.
Yeah.
See,
I wish I was smart because if I was
smart I wouldn't go out because like
when big foot,
I'm like,
I'm going to break the course record.
Right.
So was killing it.
I was up.
I was ahead by hours.
Really?
Yeah.
Hours.
But you fucked up at that one place.
We didn't have any water.
Right,
right.
So died.
So if I could go out and be smart,
that's what I'm going to try to.
Do you think he can win this mob?
I Dunno know.
I doubt it.
I know.
No,
I mean it's.
Why can't you?
Um,
well there's freaks out there.
I mean like Cameron Hanes.
No,
I don't think you're a freak.
I don't.
I just think uh,
I can push.
I think I'm good at pain management,
uh,
or ignoring pain.
But,
uh,
I had a lot of confidence when I was
doing a marathon a day.
I was,
my confidence was bar.
I've never been able to do that.
I,
I mean,
I could've done it.
I just never did it because I just,
I'm,
but isn't season's basically over now
for you,
except for doing a little blacktail
hunting Oregon.
So when will you ramp back up to a
marathon?
A day?
Well now it's a time of should I do it
or should I just just think my
training's
the bank and manage till the race
because now I could hammer too hard and
go into the race.
Fatigued.
What is the,
what day of the race?
I think it's the 13th of October.
So what does that four weeks.
Three weeks.
What's today?
Three,
three weeks.
Twenty seconds.
So how will you know?
What's the right way to do and what's
the wrong way to do it?
I don't know.
How would you know?
I wouldn't know.
Nobody knows,
but I was in their ways or people tell
whether or not they're overtrained they
monitor.
Here's what people say.
If you run a marathon,
you should not run another one for six
months.
So should I listen to them?
So yeah,
there's really no know because it's so
hard on your body and so on and so
forth.
So it,
so how do you,
what,
when you built up to a marathon a day,
how long did it take you to build up to
that?
After the 100 mile race,
which was in June,
is that what you said?
June?
Yeah.
So that's not a lot of time.
July,
August.
We're in September.
So you're talking like during July and
August you managed to build yourself up
to a marathon.
And I did a under armour,
had a mayor,
an ultra at mount bachelor in July.
Well I didn't like July 20 something.
So it was about a month after the 24
hour race.
I didn't take a day.
I think I took one day off.
So I ran every day from the 24 hour
trying to beat my body up and then I
went into that ultra and I ran that.
I don't know,
I didn't got,
took the wrong course for a couple of
miles.
So I didn't think I got seven.
I don't know what I got,
but that was 100.
Now that was a 50 k,
so that was 31 miles.
And then um,
the next day I ran the south sister,
which is a,
it was 16 miles with 5,000
feet of gain,
so I got really good mountain back to
back days there with no break after the
24 hour and then went,
then took a little break I think a day
and then started trying to get at really
at least a half marathon a day.
But then I went on a run I think of nine
days where I did a marathon every day.
And so if that time,
if you had asked if I had a chance to
win my lab,
I would have said yeah,
I,
because my confidence was amazing
because I've never been able to do that.
And maybe I'm not being realistic about
it because there could be,
you know,
Jim Walmsley show up who,
who knows what he could run it in.
And uh,
and so maybe it's not realistic,
but,
but at that time I had confidence.
Now after not running that much and
being gone hunting,
I don't know.
So when will you decide when or when we
decided like how you're going to train,
like you going to start running tomorrow
when you get back home.
I'll do a marathon tomorrow and then
once you do a marathon tomorrow I'll see
how I feel.
But in my body feels awesome right now.
Yeah,
you're rested up.
Oh God.
I feel I feel as good as I felt in a
long time right now.
Well that was the idea though,
right?
That you were going to train super hard.
Beat yourself up and then take a few
weeks off for hunting and he would
recover and recuperate.
Yep.
Looked good on paper.
Yeah.
Well,
when you,
uh,
when you run that marathon tomorrow,
you're going to feel like a fucking
animal even better than before.
Maybe I won't.
Invigorated.
Well,
come on.
What's,
what the negative self doubt talked.
Now I'm not,
it's not,
it's just how it is sometimes.
Do you think there's any advantage to
your diet that you eat all this wild
game?
Yeah.
There's gotta be like some sort of end
up with anything.
Do I can just say science,
but I think it's,
it's obvious like I was cutting up some
meat and my wife was looking at it.
She goes,
it almost looks like organ meat.
Yeah.
Because it's,
it's so rich.
I mean,
it's dark as dark and rich.
It's like if,
uh,
if you're not used to eating that type
of me,
it can affect your stomach because it's,
it's so it's rich protein and so it's
definitely more.
I don't want that
more nutrient dense and I want to say
potent almost then,
right than like a steak you'd buy at a
store.
Like dolce always likes to use that
word,
nutrient dense.
I love it's super smart.
Um,
but if you look at the protein per
ounce,
like they do,
there's a chart,
Jamie,
that they do,
um,
they compare beef,
chicken,
salmon and elk and Moose and it's off
the charts.
It's double.
So
you could get the same amount of protein
that you get in a 16 ounce steak,
I think in like an eight ounce piece of
elk.
So you need less and it's more potent
and it just,
it just looks different.
You know,
I've,
I've shown it to friends that have never
eaten out before the like Jesus because
it's just read it just,
just dense,
you know,
you're eating a super athlete and that's
what it's like.
No,
and that's what I feel like I feel like
when I'm eating at,
you know,
those elk are amazing animals,
powerful,
strong endurance.
Um,
you know,
everything I would like to be as far as
of taking on anything that happens and
uh,
you know,
when you eat it,
how could you not have confidence or
feel better by just think it's the best
food for you?
I really do.
I mean,
I feel fucking fantastic.
I feel better now at 50 than I've ever
felt like probably in my life.
Right.
I feel better at 50 than I did at 40.
Really?
Yeah,
for sure.
Definitely just brought a lot of it is
eating really healthy,
really running,
managing my,
um,
my sleep,
that's a big one.
That's one that you don't do that very
good and you don't really get a lot of
sleep.
It's that stupid job.
I'm supposed to be at work right now.
So when you get to Friday,
but you make more money outside your
stupid job than you do on your stupid
job.
Son,
I need to manage.
You need to listen to me.
Yeah.
Every time we talk about this we do,
we talk about it a lot.
You're the opposite of me in that regard
because I'm like captain cut ties and
burned the bridge and fucking throw
kerosene on the house.
Light on fire and drive away.
Woo.
Yeah.
And you're not.
I know.
Opposite.
Yeah.
I'm a,
you know,
in part of it is,
um,
I've never,
like I said,
I've never felt special so I've always
feel like I should appreciate having a
good job and uh,
I'm loyal to,
to where I work and so I feel like all
this opportunity and these things that I
do and being on your show and all that
could go away tomorrow.
And then,
uh,
if I quit the job I'd be like,
Oh my God,
I knew it.
I'm going to fricking loser.
And I quit it.
The best job I've ever had in my entire
life.
And that's an interesting way of looking
at it.
But it's,
I'm part of your strength is the fact
that you can endure.
Right?
And so I think you're in during this
job.
Maybe I like being miserable,
but I'm not because I liked the people
at work.
Do you do,
but you would like it more if you didn't
have to be there.
Yeah,
I would like just to check in with them
every once in a while.
Hey,
how's everybody?
Yeah.
How's,
how's that place where I used to work
for my whole life?
Yeah.
I mean,
so I,
I missed.
I miss the people when I'm not there.
I'm,
I miss problem solving and,
and,
uh,
helping people,
um,
you know,
achieve goals.
So I,
I like being there for that.
I've been thinking about this a lot and
I've been trying to figure out what,
what a solution is,
but you know,
maybe we could talk to a hoyt about this
or some,
you know,
some company about this,
maybe you under armour,
but the idea of putting together like
almost like camps where people could
learn archery and maybe you could give
seminars.
Guys like Dudley can show some archery
techniques.
Guys like Remy Warren can talk about
things and putting together these almost
like introductory camps.
Yeah,
where people don't know where to start
or where to start.
I didn't know where to start.
If it wasn't for Steve Rinella,
I would've never got to start in
hunting.
It wasn't for you.
I would've never got started behind.
It's just sometimes you need someone and
there's not a lot of resources out
there,
but there's a lot of people that are
listening.
There's a lot of people that they're
hearing all this and that,
wow,
this sounds crazy.
Like I want to get involved in this,
and again,
a lot of what we're talking about,
like I was talking about Brian Barney's
podcast,
like he's hunting public land over the
counter tags in Montana.
You could go get them.
They don't cost that much.
You Go,
you pay your license fee,
he buy a tag and you can go out into the
wilderness.
You just need a tent and a backpack and
a bow and Arrow and guts and just go out
there and you could.
You could handle it.
There's,
there's,
there's a lot of opportunity like that
in this country is amazing for that.
It's one of the few countries in the
world where we have literally millions
of acres of public land that are all
yours and mine and I was wearing that
back country hunters and anglers tee
shirt yesterday that says public land
owner.
Yeah.
We're all public land owners and it's,
it's,
it's a very,
very important thing to support and it
is an amazing resource.
So yeah,
like where we're at.
Utah is super rare and not a lot of
people get to go there,
but guess what?
You could go to Idaho,
Idaho.
You can go into the back country in
Idaho and get amazing public land
hunting.
If you're willing to hike in and go deep
and you go to google earth and you could
go in and look at all these basins and
mountains and you could go online and
ask people and there's ways to move
around.
There's ways to do this,
but getting started is insanely
difficult and I've been thinking about
this that maybe we could do something
like,
you know,
how they have that total archery
challenge that they did in Utah.
What were there I was is awesome.
Amazing.
Right.
So maybe there's like a gathering that
we could put together like maybe once a
year,
maybe during the off season,
just once a year where people can get
maybe fitted for a bow.
You sign up for this in advance and
maybe it's a couple day thing,
like maybe one or two days where you go
through an introductory course of,
of archery,
understanding it and then maybe someone
can talk about shot placement and maybe
someone else like someone who does a lot
of soul hunting,
like remy or maybe even Adam can talk
about like woodsmanship and things that
you can learn and here's some books you
could read like your book back country.
What was your country bowhunting and
that's still in print,
right?
Because to by that,
is it on Amazon?
No,
it's on Cameron Hanes.com.
Au put,
powerful shout out to Cameron Hanes.com,
but to have those kinds of things like
s,
like set out like,
Hey,
this is something you can do,
this is something you could read.
This is something you can listen to be
awesome.
I mean,
we've done gatherings,
you know,
Wayne at the Iraq,
he,
we used to do this,
bell hunters,
I can't remember what we used to call
it,
but six or 700 people would show up at
the sale rack in the parking lot,
big tent.
And we do things.
We could do it out where I practice out
of his property,
you know,
um,
and get together and have people in and
it would just be,
it would be amazing.
Why don't we do that.
The reason I know that there's so much
interest in Pat,
my book back country Bolony and I wrote
in 2006 cases of that go out every day.
I mean,
before I left on this hunt,
I sat at my kitchen table and sign books
for on,
uh,
cases of books because those are all
going to be gone when I get home.
Do you have a time machine,
a time machine?
Why?
Where do you get the time?
I don't understand how the fuck you have
time to run a marathon and then signed
books and then practice bowhunting.
Do 100 reps and fucking this.
And I've done that with your family than
dinner and go to sleep and then work a
full time job and then
he is tough.
But uh,
but that's how I know that um,
there's so much interest in that is that
book is,
you know,
I think sold almost 40,000
of them and people have that dream just
you have to.
Oh Nice.
Um,
and uh,
I just,
I'm a good example of people living that
dream.
This guy at work,
two guys at my work,
they wanted to do the back country
thing.
So we got maps and Wyoming.
I said,
here's [inaudible].
Roy went there at one time,
I've killed a couple of bowls in the
back country.
Their public land is a pretty easy tag
draw.
You can get a,
you put in for the,
for the premium tag.
It costs a little more to put in,
but the odds of getting it or you can
get it on.
I got it almost every year,
a couple times and then or a year in
between.
And so they put in for the tag.
They got the tag.
I sat down with him,
said showed them the drainage's,
showed them I'd hunt here,
I'd camp here,
I do this.
And they went in there,
killed a bull.
I mean public land never been there
before.
I had a dream of doing it.
Made it happen.
So it's,
it happens guys do it every year.
It can be done.
Yeah,
for sure.
Can go from the beginning.
From no knowledge of archery to
eventually doing it.
Yep.
And stomps.
Done it.
I know,
I know.
He texted me today and he's a fucking
animal.
Yeah.
I love Andy's Austin.
He got obsessed with bowhunting from
listening to us talk about it.
We'll was talking archery.
He got a toy.
He got set up.
Dudley gave him some coaching.
I know you hang.
You hung out with them and he went
hunting with Dudley and he got a giant
fucking black bear.
Two of them.
He got.
He got a bear.
He killed a couple of days.
Yeah.
Oh,
excuse me.
And then he,
he went on a bad run.
Had a frustrating elocon centralized.
Yeah.
Five shots.
But he did a podcast,
I guess,
about it today.
He,
he told me that today's podcast,
I think it's about failure and about bow
hunting and about failure and a cleared
hot.
This is a name of his pocket,
cleared hot.
But,
um,
man,
I love that guy.
I told him I'm on the way home.
I was going to listen to his podcast
today.
He said he,
he talked about,
he mentioned to me or something like
that for people who don't know.
He's been on the podcast before and he
is,
um,
he's a retired navy seal who has the
world record holder in the distance of
one of those fucking crazy squirrel
suits.
He's a maniac.
He's a real maniac.
And he's become completely obsessed with
bow hunting.
In fact,
moved to Montana.
Yeah,
that's how savage that guy is.
He's like,
fuck this,
I'm out of California,
moves his family from San Diego to
Montana and he's doing,
you know,
over the counter what Montana is one of
the best places in the world where you
can get over the counter tags for elk
hunting.
Yeah.
And just the wilderness.
They're like,
I told you when I went there last summer
with my family,
we had to stop the car and I brought by
nose and I was given it to my kids.
I'm like,
look,
there's 100 elk out here in this field.
And we were just sitting there staring
for like,
Shit.
We pulled over for like a half an hour
just looking out the window at a hundred
hours just hanging out on this field.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
Uh,
Montana's awesome.
No,
no,
Andy,
he was,
wasn't he seal for 17 years?
Yeah,
I mean,
so just savage stud.
Just a great guy too.
You know,
just got a great mind for success and
this is why he became obsessed with bow
hunting as well.
It's like he,
he recognized the things that we were
talking about and he decided to start it
to start the process and see what it was
like and then immediately became
obsessed.
Yeah.
And then as we talked about also hit.
I mean,
it's tough.
Yeah.
He had a hard time.
I mean he had some good success when
Dudley was coaching him.
Is that his place there to get that many
people have asked why we moved to
Montana and the other questions.
The only regret is not making the move
sooner.
Yeah.
Look at that view.
I know.
It's insane.
Alex.
he's just got his truck parked there and
saw some amazing,
amazing view.
He said something.
I think I saw common lake kind of looks
like it has a yard.
No fucking Amen.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
I think he said something about,
um,
and maybe it was on that queered hot,
that other posts there.
The second post.
Yeah,
about that.
Maybe on his last shot,
he would have been better off throwing
his bow one week a to two in one week of
choice.
I have to take in talking about failure
in episode 13,
I had one of the best weeks I've ever
had.
I have in a long time.
My mind kept drifting back to motivation
and purpose,
which my opinion is the opposite side of
the coin.
That failure sits on,
hopefully something in it clicks for
you.
So this is,
um,
he's talking about his episode of a
cleared hottest podcast,
which is an excellent podcast.
She go and check that shit out.
He's just good at verbalizing and I mean
it's just so easy to listen to.
He's a very smart dude.
So that's him out there with his bow.
Yeah,
just to.
And he says he.
What did he say about humble pie?
That's bell hunting right there.
Well,
it's fucking hard and anytime you think
you're good.
Yeah.
So I mean,
something happens and you just feel
like,
I don't know.
Well,
you know,
Douglas talked about that,
like Dudley who was a guy who literally
gets flown out to Europe to coach
international teams.
He's coached Olympic teams.
He was talking about like one time he
went with an outfitter and he just
hadn't been practicing enough.
He felt like he was fine and he just
fucking missing.
He's like,
what?
And he's like,
he took a whole day.
He goes,
look,
tomorrow we're not going out.
And he goes,
I'm just going to sit here and I'm going
to put up a fucking block target and I'm
going to practice.
I'm going to get my mind,
get back on.
And then he got back on track and then
the next day killed really next time
shooting.
Perfect.
But it's like he needed to have that
wake up call that even though he's John
fucking Dudley,
world class professional archer,
if you don't practice,
it doesn't matter the,
the,
the Arrow doesn't care to animals don't
care if you think you're a bad
motherfucker.
It doesn't mean you have to have 100
percent dedication,
100 percent focus all the time.
And that was one of the things that I
really loved about this week is that
even though there was times that it was
kind of,
it was exhausting for sure.
And there was times it can be kind of
frustrating where you're on an animal.
Like I didn't feel frustrated.
Like I wanted to quit,
I felt frustrated like I wanted to press
on and I wanted to get successful
income.
Being friends with guys like you guys
like remy,
Adam Green Tree.
Just knowing these people that have done
all this and gone through all this
already,
just.
And also for people that are listening,
having podcasts where people like you or
like remy or Steven Rinella can talk
about the struggle.
Yeah.
It's so important,
right?
Because what gets attention is this
success.
Yeah.
Like when you watch a TV show,
what do you see guys shooting animals so
easy.
Yeah,
it does.
Because you get,
you get a TV shows,
21 minutes,
you got some sponsors you've got to
mention,
you get a few minutes of hunting and
I'll hear they killed something.
That's one of the things that I'm
worried about with these films because
these films are brilliant.
Like your film,
that time film that under armour made.
They're brilliant.
But man,
it seems like everything just kind of
happened in that.
Like all of a sudden there's the elk.
You passed up,
you were at full job.
Nah,
not that one too young,
and then there's a perfect one.
Perfect shot.
He's down in seconds.
Everybody's happy,
but that's not.
That's not the thing.
The thing is the hours and hours and
hours of hiking and the disappointment,
the fucking wind goddess,
goddammit.
Like we were in on this bowl and the
wind shifted and the cows go milk the
cows.
Bark bark for people don't know a cow
elk.
When they hear things or smell things
and see things and they know something's
wrong,
they go
and it reverberates through the woods
and everybody knows what that sound is.
Sucks of fat Dick.
Everybody went when a cow wouldn't just
one cow something or smell something
barks.
Everybody's like,
oh,
I mean that was it.
It's over.
There was a time,
Jamison and Colton and I,
before I killed that bull.
We were standing there dead still for
five minutes.
What?
Cows are just staring at us just staring
and you're not moving like your feet are
going numb.
Your knee hurts because you're kind of
like leaning on the side of a hill.
You can't move.
You just get to stay and they're just
looking right at you because for them,
look,
for me,
it's a pursuit.
It's a discipline.
It's,
it's,
it's.
I don't want to say fun.
It's exhilarating and intense.
It's amazing.
It says that I'm attracted to it.
For them it's life and death and they
don't have a language.
They don't have a brain that processes
all these variables.
They just know that's fucking danger.
Yeah.
It might be dangerous.
That's not.
Is that something that looks to eat me?
They know they're delicious.
They must,
yeah.
Um,
one one thing you know,
on that hunt and we had basically a
lifetime worth of experience for a lot
of guys in a week,
you know,
up there and um,
because the,
the timing was perfect.
It,
there's a few reasons why it was a
perfect storm up there is the weather
was a storm obviously,
but a lot of snow.
It was awesome.
Yeah.
One day we got hammered with snow,
but the moon phase,
the moon was basically nonexistent the
last few days.
And that's a big thing when the moon is
full.
Animals are out at night feeding.
Most of their feeding is done at night
and a little bit during the day to.
I'm on this week,
they're,
the moon phase was down,
so they were feeding mostly out during
the day.
So that was big.
The weather was good and then at the
time of year so that the bulls were
reading.
But um,
I just remember one specific and I can't
wait to show this on the film,
but we were,
there was a bowl bukedde when we heard
it up there in the,
in the quake ease.
And he was going crazy.
We want to try to get a good look at
them.
So we're standing there and mark womack,
who sub segments his company,
he was filming me and he looks over and
he says,
Ken,
there's bull bedded right there.
And it was about a little over 100 yards
away.
There was a six by six bedded and uh,
with the wind the way it was a Michael,
I'm going to go see how close I can get
to them.
So I snuck up there and got within 10
feet of this six by six bowl and I got
so close,
there was a,
there was a tree blocking his,
his eye wear.
Normally he'd be able to see me,
but he,
where he bedded the tree was blocking
that.
So I use that tree and uses the cover of
the wind to get in close and that's on,
like you said,
a wild animal that only cares about
staying alive essentially and for the
bull breeding.
But that is a,
that was an experience I got so close
that I was like,
okay,
if he,
he's going to know I'm here eventually,
what am I going?
How close am I going to get?
What's he going to do?
Because they're,
they're aggressive.
This time of year,
testosterone is skyrocketed because our
breeding and they're fighting.
They're doing all of this thing.
What's he gonna do when he sees me this
close?
So I didn't really know for sure,
but I felt that wind shift a little bit
at and I felt it on the back of my neck.
So I came to full draw.
He's 10 feet away and he stands up and
he's like,
he knew right then I'm standing plain as
day.
Once he stood up and we've got an image
I'll post up here in a second of me at
full draw 10 feet on this big bull
elephant.
Credible.
But the footage is amazing.
That's going to be cool to show.
Now the footage is going to be amazing.
And we also got footage of a bullet.
Um,
we couldn't shoot because even though he
was a huge bowl,
he was a younger bull who was probably
five or six years old and it was in the
snow and it was 40 yards away,
broadside,
screaming his lungs out.
We're just standing there going,
wow,
this is crazy.
He's just standing on top of the
mountain going,
where's my batch?
Has to.
Most people like when you're on public
land,
like when I used to hunt the Eagle cap
wilderness,
that bull's dead or I'm going to try to
kill that bowl or you gotten.
There's all sorts of things that can
happen,
you know,
when you're shooting an arrow.
But uh,
the reason why where we were hunting and
so good is because it's so well managed
because normally,
so it's five or six years old,
that's a hell of a trophy for anybody on
public land.
But when everybody can come together and
say,
okay guys,
here's what we're going to do,
we're only going to kill the eight to 10
year old bulls.
You let those bulls grow and then you
get an amazing.
That's,
that's one reason why Arizona so good.
Um,
they,
they do,
they manage it for trophy animals and
uh,
some places in New Mexico,
Mexico is good.
Um,
there's a place in Oregon is the
[inaudible] or I put in for and it's
public land,
but it's a really hard tagged drop and
putting in for,
for 17 years now,
but they only give they,
they were getting 10,
I think now they give 20 tags a year and
there's big bulls there and it's just
because it's managed.
So there's a few different places that
are managed older animals,
but if you're just going straight up
public land,
it's really hard to pass up a five or
six year old boy.
Now how do they make that decision to
only give 20 tax?
Because it's probably,
I would imagine thousands of people that
are trying to draw.
Yeah,
these tags and only 20 people get an
opportunity to.
How do they make that distinction just
by the biologists pick the number of
animals.
Yeah.
They just do some sort of a survey and
find out how many of their animals and
also some places managed for better
genetics and higher potential of what
they would call.
You know,
there's a real problem with that word
trophy because people think,
oh,
you just want to decorate your wall.
That animal's body.
No.
You trophy hunter or do you eat?
I'm like both.
Yeah.
Well the truth is an intense experience
with a mature animal that has a lot of
x,
a lot of lifetime of surviving.
You know,
like it's a way different animal.
Like if when you're around a young bold,
they don't know anything.
They're like babies.
Well they know spike,
they barely know what's going on.
Like what are you a spikes been alive
for a year and a half.
Right?
So that's where the herd protects them.
Elk are herd animals,
they look out for each other.
So when you have an eight to 10 year old
bull that has a protection of the herd
but also has,
has been around for eight to 10 hunting
seasons.
That's a smart animal.
He seen some shit.
He's seen some stuff and it's a smart
animal.
So,
um,
there was a guy in camp also that has
hunted the San Carlos,
um,
Indian reservation and he talked about
this big bolt there.
That new is being hunted,
circled around them,
came in from the backside of the hunters
to look at him because he was that,
that bull had been around and knew what
was going on so much and so they were
able to track them and see what he did
and he went around behind the hunters.
And so these animals would imagine,
I mean,
this is where they live every day for
eight to 10 years.
You,
you see some stuff,
you learn where humans as hunters like
to go.
So we're probably a minor threat in
comparison to the mountain lions.
Yeah.
We're talking about how many cats are on
this ranch,
right?
There's,
there's,
but they know humans are danger.
I mean they know that.
And then like I said,
they know.
So,
so there are certain places where
hunters,
regardless of who's there,
go to glass,
go to call.
And those elk know that,
okay,
I see something there.
That's where I've seen a human.
Whatever they think a human is before
I'm not going there,
you know.
So it's um,
once you get an age on an animal,
it gets tough.
It gets tough to get him killed and I
would imagine
mountain lion population as high as it
is,
like they have to be on point 24 slash
seven with something that's faster than
them killed.
Kills them with its teeth.
Yeah.
Something that can leap up and literally
a hold of its neck.
Remember we were talking to Johnny in
Colorado and he was telling us about the
footprints that he found.
They found a bunch of cat footprints and
then they found a bunch of elk
footprints and then they only found the
elk footprints and then a couple hundred
yards later they found a dead bowl with
a giant mountain lion clinging to its
neck.
Like that's,
that's a hard life when a fucking 150
pound cat and bring down a thousand
pound bull.
Yeah.
So the.
So the line was on the Bulls back,
so,
so that's why it's,
it's uh,
it,
some prince were gone and the snow
because he was up on the bull trying to
get it killed.
The bull was taken off for a couple
hundred yards.
Finally the cat club down on probably
it's wind pipe.
Got Killed and that's happening outside
of season.
That's tiny.
That's happening every day,
every day.
That's not,
that's not hunting season.
That's just real life out there.
So airs.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So it's.
But we kind of started to talk about the
trophy hunting aspect of what people,
you know,
when they have that,
that trophy hunting moniker that is,
it has negative connotation and that's
what we talked about this a little bit
last night on the way back from the
airport,
the grizzly hunting in British Columbia,
you know,
that they're stopping that November,
there'll be no more grizzly hunting.
They were killing 250 barrels a year out
of 15,000.
So they're basically just managing the
population,
you know,
you have to take a certain amount of
animals out given the habitat and the
carrying capacity of the land,
especially predators because they don't
have predators.
Right,
right.
Because what else is going to kill a
Grizzly,
right?
Nothing,
nothing.
So people say,
well,
the,
you know,
they'll,
their numbers will drop down on their
own if they're,
if they eat all the deer and all the
moves,
you're right,
their numbers will drop down,
but it will take decades.
Yeah,
and if you're in that time,
you're going to destroy two different
things,
right?
You're going to destroy the ungulates,
they're going to get devastated and
you're going to also destroy the economy
that comes with hunting.
[inaudible] like the economy that comes
with hunting,
those ungulates because they're going to
get devastated by the overwhelming
population of grizzly bears in the
economy that comes with hunting.
The grizzly bears,
which in managing them,
what they're going to have to probably
do is what they've done with mountain
lions in California where people don't
know because mountain lion hunting is
outlawed in California.
So what they do is they hire hunters to
kill mountain lions and they've killed,
I believe they killed almost a hundred
last year.
I think it was like 97.
Most of them,
they find pets in their body.
They find like their primary food source
more than 50 percent of dogs.
Right?
And they just killing people's dogs.
So the lions are still getting killed.
Yeah,
but there's just not a hunter is doing
it.
It's government basically shoot,
they can run dogs with them,
they can do all sorts of things to get
them killed.
But it's a government paying somebody to
do it as opposed to hunter's pain for
the opportunity to do it to kill the
same amount.
So instead of money going to the state,
the state's paying money and it's a lot
of money,
especially when you're talking about
something like grizzly bears,
grizzly bear,
what they're saying up there.
And I,
I,
you know,
did some research on it just because I
want to know how this works because why
it got was being stopped.
It's just public outcry.
And the new government in British
Columbia said,
I'm in this day and age,
you know,
the public just can't stomach grizzly
trophy hunting.
So the public,
what the hell does the public know?
The public doesn't even.
They're not even out there where they
have a misconception and their their
ideas all based on them being in the
cities and the major population center
of British Columbia in Vancouver.
It's a big urban liberal.
Yeah,
probably a lot of different people.
Their camera.
You don't have to be generalizing to
find.
Probably they could have voted for
Obama.
They would've.
So these people that live in Vancouver,
they come comprise the majority of the
people that are voting in British
Columbia,
and so they voted out the grizzly bear
hunting,
but these people like that I know like
my friend Mike Hawk Ridge who lives in
BC.
Yeah.
Mike's had a lot of experience with
grizzly bears and wolves.
Wolves up there are so plentiful.
They don't have a bag limit on them.
You can shoot as many wolves as you want
to encourage you to shoot wolves.
There's even a bounty in some places on
wolves.
Well,
and do you know,
so I think this was a little different
up there with the bears.
I don't think they voted it out per se.
I think the new government came in.
They took a poll and said who supports
grizzly hunting and whatever 71 or 74
percent said they were opposed,
so the new government just said,
okay,
we're going to make the decision to stop
it.
Well,
they didn't stop it.
This is what they did.
You can hunt the grizzlies for meat,
but you can't keep the rug or the skull
or the skull,
the hider,
the skull,
which people consider trophies.
Right.
But what the problem with that is that
is also a resource.
You're,
you're eliminating a resource.
If you shoot a bear and you eat the
bear,
why wouldn't you keep the rug,
like have a bear rug in your house to
commemorate that experience.
And also it's,
you know,
people have bare skin rugs.
It's always been.
I had about 50 of them,
but it's,
it's something that people,
you know,
like if you're eating the animal that is
also a part of the animal,
why would you be compelled to throw that
away?
That seems incredibly wasteful.
No,
it's disrespectful,
right?
It's also disrespectful to just shoot an
animal just for its skin.
If you're a type of person was to shoot
an elephant,
just take the tusks and let them meet
Rod.
A lot of people think that's
disrespectful.
That's where trophy hunting gets its bad
monica.
So what they've done is the opposite of
what makes sense.
You've or you've removed part of the
value of that animal and you've also
removed most of the economy of people
hunting that animal.
So most people are not going to hunt
them.
What they said was,
so they were killing 250 a year and
they could get like out of country or or
whoever,
whatever hunters to pay $25,000
to hunt those bare.
So it was 25,000
times 250.
It's like a lot.
I don't know,
it's like stupid.
Over a thousand dollars
it seems.
They're both stupid.
But anyway,
so that money,
just like the lines of dollars,
just like the lion hunting.
Oh God,
I should be able to figure that out.
I don't want it to Jamie a hundred.
How many tags they give?
Two hundred and 50.
Two hundred 50 times 20 slash 25,000.
What does that smart people say?
Figured it out.
I'm going to get take.
Yes,
I don't know.
Fifty dollars million.
You'd have to have a pen and paper,
say $50 million,
6 million,
250,
whatever dollars always wrong,
so think of that.
Now think that's the money that's gone.
That money is now no longer going into
the economy.
Now they're going to have what they call
problem bears.
Now problem bears are bears that attack
people,
which is very frequent bears that attack
animals,
livestock,
bears that encroach upon people's
established residences and communities
and start eating garbage cans and
killing pets and things along those
lines.
Then they have to hire people to go out
and kill these bears,
and that's going to cost thousands of
dollars a day.
You're going to have to pay for
equipment dogs.
They usually have to track them with
dogs.
These dogs have to be trained.
You have to get specialists.
Who knows you're doing tends to be more
than one because they need backup
because you didn't know a thousand pound
animal.
I don't know if you want dogs on a
grizzly.
I think that's how they find them.
I don't know.
I think that's black bear.
No.
One of the guys that was on a Grizzly,
a greedy Bowman podcast was totally
about it.
Dogs at the grizzly.
Yeah.
That they use dogs.
Dogs wouldn't last long.
Well,
I don't think they engage the grizzly.
I think they find them,
you know,
and bark at him and obey him up and then
they,
they locate them and then that's when
the hunter comes in.
Okay.
But that's the other thing that people
don't like.
That idea of using dogs to hunt animals,
but that's one of the more effective
ways to find these animals.
It's one of the best ways they use in a
lot of states to find mountain lions and
people think it's fucked up and cruel.
The only effective way to hunt mountain
lions to be,
to be honest.
I mean,
you can gamble,
you might see one,
have a tag.
I mean I buy a tag in Oregon every year.
I've seen about.
I said,
I think I've seen three mountain lions
in 30 years.
I have a tag.
I mean I've had a shot one time didn't
get killed,
but if you have dogs then you can say
okay,
we have,
we have 10,000
mountain lions,
um,
we need to take out,
you know,
$500 a year.
So like a lot of states have once
because once you kill a lion then you
have to go to game and fish and get it
checked in.
They do measurements to do all this,
all these different things.
And so once 500 lines of come in,
the season stops,
right?
So they have a,
a mortality threshold.
You have to have that.
Once they reached that limit,
they said,
well we have 10,000,
we need to kill 500 a year.
So once we kill 500 season's over.
And why would you want to kill them
online?
I don't understand.
Well,
first of all,
you,
you to control again the population of
predators because nothing else does and
to,
you can eat mountain lions and there are
apparently delicious.
Yeah.
You had it.
No,
I never have.
No.
I know people that have written,
Allah says it's absolutely delicious.
He shot them out in line last year for
the first time.
He's had it before,
but he's never had his own instead.
It was sensational.
Now I definitely eat it.
I want.
I'd like to hunt lion and never have
before and you know,
using the dogs.
The dogs are a tool.
They're a tool,
like a bow,
like a rifle.
It's just those dogs have been trained
so well and love what they do.
The owners love the dogs and that's
just.
I mean there's,
I don't know,
it's such a special bond between them
and then just being part of that is just
another amazing hunting experience.
It's just a different tool to use.
Yeah,
well I think people think of dogs as
being only pets and that's what they
should be used as in dog shouldn't work,
but you know,
that is an.
I understand that because I have pets
and no,
I wouldn't want Marshall to go out and
get attack.
Barsha would shit his pants if even saw
a bear,
but this.
There's different kinds of dogs that
were bred for a very specific purpose.
That's what those dogs want to do.
They do it.
That's one of the things that Aaron
Schneider talked about in the podcast
where he was standing in the wrong place
when they opened up the pen to let the
grizzly dogs out and the dog just leaped
and slammed him in the chest.
And it just about really,
I'm unconscious.
Which podcast is this?
It's one of the Gritty Bowman podcasts.
The more recent ones.
Let me see if I could pull up the number
because I was listening to it recently.
Oh,
greedy bowman is a very good podcast,
uh,
by these guys that have Ryan as far as
Brian call and Aaron Snyder and I'm the
number episode two 81 to 82.
And um,
and there was another one in there,
but to 82 is the,
I think the big one.
It's about Predator management with a
bark.
Bart Lancaster,
and that's the one where they really
talked about.
They talked about guys who lived there
in British Columbia who were talking
about how when he's not home and he has
to go somewhere,
he has to leave his dog with his wife.
If his wife goes riding a horse,
he has to bring.
The wife has to bring dogs with her
because there's so many fucking grizzly
bears out there.
They have to have something that's going
to protect him,
warn him,
and these dogs are not just pets.
They're also a first line of defense.
The let them know that there's danger in
the area,
let them know that bears near and also
keep the bears away because the bears
here,
dogs,
they don't want to fuck around and the
dogs start barking.
That means people are going to know that
means outcome the guns.
Right?
Right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Good deterrent for sure.
People in Vancouver didn't understand
this.
They're not there.
They just sitting there eating Tofu and
you know,
and,
and talking about spirituality and you
know,
and then they,
they pass these bands and they upset the
entire balance of nature.
They upset the economy,
the economy of hunting of conservation.
All these things get good all lopsided
and it's.
I understand where they're coming from.
I understand the sentiment,
but it's a lot of it is entirely based
on the images that people have seen in
movies and Disney films and the
anthropomorphization of these animals.
Will you attach human characteristics to
these ultra predators,
these enormous monsters of nature,
which are amazing.
We don't like.
I can speak for myself,
but I know I'm speaking for you too.
We don't want bears to not be there.
We don't want wolves to not be there.
They're amazing.
I'm glad that they exist.
They're fucking awesome.
I mean to be outside.
I've never heard a wolf howl.
Well I did once.
I did it with Hawk Ridge in BC,
but they were like way in the distance,
heard wolves howl,
but to see them and be there when it's
happening and I saw a grizzly bear wants
in in Alberta and just to look at it,
it's like,
Holy Shit.
You see those things.
It's amazing.
I mean it's,
it's magical,
but that doesn't mean that they don't
need to be managed in that weird word.
Right.
That's,
and that's what people say is like,
well,
why are we interfere,
interfering?
Why can't they had figured out
themselves they have forever and what
people don't fail to realize,
I guess is no man's always been
involved.
Yeah,
we've always hunted.
Yeah.
We've,
you know,
we've been involved in how many animals
are,
are sometimes we've been involved
natively like when we almost wiped out
the elk or the Buffalo,
but lately we've been involved
positively and we manage them
and this is the other thing they talked
about on the greedy Bowman podcast where
they really emphasize the difference
between a biologist who's not in the
field and these,
these,
all these different people,
whether it's the,
uh,
the,
the hunters themselves or whether it's
the guides or whether it's the people
that are outfitters that are there 24
slash seven,
three 65.
They can give you more data.
They understand the real numbers is very
difficult when you're dealing with,
especially something like British
Columbia,
intensely wooded area to get a real
number.
I mean,
there's no map.
There's no like you can't just pull up
the social security numbers of the bears
and find out how many of them are still
alive and he
can't.
He can't fly over and get account,
like to do a lot of animals like Caribou
or something who will caribou or it even
elk where they winter,
so elk,
you know,
once once winter hits,
they get pushed down to where they can
get feed in the winter.
That's where they get to the counts
right now and so that's where they can
get a pretty good number or an idea of
how many elk are in that area.
Bear don't do you.
You're never going to fly over there.
No wintering grounds for bear.
Well,
that's another important thing that Adam
found out.
What Adam Green tree was on this crazy
walkabout that he was doing for the last
month.
He found mountain grizzlies would.
He believes and he says,
and I know that he's a very smart guy.
He's been around a lot of animals.
He believes is 100 percent mountain
grizzlies in Colorado.
That's what he said.
He took pictures of them and he even put
up photos.
They're really hard to see pictures way
off in the distance,
but even put a photo up of,
you know,
online.
He did online searches for that mountain
range in Colorado.
They said that it's like people who see
big foot,
they say they see grizzlies,
but he's like,
he's.
He spotted four of them.
Yeah.
So I mean that,
that's a good example.
I mean,
if those were grizzly,
then there's grizzly.
We didn't know about how many people are
going to do with Adam did and actually
go out there 20 plus miles deep into the
woods with a fucking tent and find these
things.
It's incredibly difficult to get real
world numbers on these animals.
Yep.
And that's.
So once you,
once you take,
um,
once you take the science out of it and
the,
the people with boots on the ground
actually weighing in on,
hey,
here's how,
here's how many animals are,
here's how many we need to kill.
Once you do,
like they did NBC and the Government
just decides that the public can't
stomach it anymore because they did.
Some poll at stars,
they have starbucks in BC,
right?
Yes.
A pole at starbucks and uh,
which is where I went in today by the
way,
but I still kill stuff.
Um,
uh,
that's when,
that's where we cause problems.
We create issues.
We,
you know,
we use the wrong tools to.
We're still managing the,
the animals but not correctly.
Well,
it's also the decisions are based on
emotions without real information based
on the actual environment that these
animals live in.
Like you,
you could never imagine if you lived in
Vancouver and which some of the best
restaurants in the world and drove some
of the nicest streets and I mean
Vancouver is an amazing city.
If you live there and you had this idea
of what wildlife is,
but you never left Vancouver if you.
Did you.
Oh,
we visited Chicago.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Now like you don't know,
like you literally have to be there to
just kind of get a sense of it and you
wouldn't get a sense of it in one trip.
You'd have to be there all the time.
You'd have to,
you'd have to take multiple excursions
into the forest to really understand
what you're talking about,
what you're dealing with.
So to make those decisions based on
people who are completely ignorant about
that situation.
Right?
It's like,
it's crazy.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's a ridiculous way to handle it.
So,
so thankfully here in the United States,
we do have a great system for wildlife
management and our government,
except for here in California with the
mountain lions trust the professionals,
the biologists,
the people out,
you know,
boots on the ground as I said,
and we,
we trust those people to allocate tags
to give us numbers to,
to help manage the hunt seasons and,
and how many tags are for each area.
So thankfully that's continued to happen
here,
but even here it's,
it gets protested.
It gets the delisting of wolves and area
where they're starting to desert,
desolate or devastating of grizzlies
surface.
And that's going to get pushed back to
and people are going to sue against it.
But the idea is not to kill all these
animals.
The idea is not to to satisfy the
bloodthirsty urges,
some fat redneck that people have in
their mind as being the stereotypical
hunter that they see as a bad guy in a
movie.
Right?
Like in a movie,
it's always like,
remember the scene of Wolverine where
there's are the bad guys that killed the
bear and he goes and fucks those bad
guys up,
but you shoot that bear with poison or
or something like that.
Drinking.
It's lighthearted.
It's so stereotypical.
It's like the idea that every beautiful
woman has to be stupid.
It's just as offensive.
Right?
And this is the stereotype that we've
been fed because it's a,
it's a classic cliche sort of a
scenario,
right?
It's easy.
You see it in the movie,
right?
Jocks are big,
dumb,
stupid guys.
A hot girls are bimbos.
You know,
the nerdy guy with glasses is always
smart.
Sometimes those nerdy guys with glasses
are fucking idiots.
Yeah.
You know,
it doesn't sometimes a hot girls hot
girls way smarter than us.
It's all hunters aren't.
Most Times that's the thing that
frustrates the shit out of me.
My experience has been like what we
experienced this past weekend.
People like Lee and Tiffany,
people like you and Ben.
Really good people.
Really good.
Nice people.
Yeah.
I mean,
we know so many people that are involved
in the outdoor world,
whether the hunting world street,
yeah.
Yeah.
Whether it's John Dudley or remy or
Steve Rinella.
These are great people.
They're exceptional human beings.
People with exceptional character and
exceptional discipline right there.
It's not the fat redneck that wants a
poisoning.
Grizzly bear that Wolverine has to beat
up in the stupid movie.
Right?
But that's all you see.
No,
and I,
I even,
I did a call out on,
um,
it was like some triple x movie or
Xander's cage.
Somebody,
I don't know what it was,
but they had the girl on there said
there's the,
they show these bowhunters getting ready
to shoot.
Did we talk about this on the last time
getting ready to,
or maybe I just put my on my facebook
getting ready to shoot a lion with a
bow.
She's with a rifle with the rifle scope
on his head.
She shoots the hunter and she says,
so a vin diesel calls were on the phone
about some mission they're going to do
for the stupid movie,
and he says,
what are you up to?
She's like,
even in the odds.
So she was shooting a hunter and that's
on a,
on a regular movie.
So corny.
He talked to people in Africa.
They want lions
dead.
[inaudible] lions killed their friends.
Yeah.
Like I know a woman who lived in South
Africa who lost a friend to a lion.
Yeah.
And when you talk to her about,
she has that South African accent.
She's born and raised and you know,
when she talks about lions,
she goes,
they just never been around lions,
you know,
see what she goes.
You don't know what it's like.
There was a,
there was an article that was written by
a guy from Zimbabwe right after the
whole season will cecil the lion thing
that was in the New York Times that said
in Zimbabwe,
we do not cry for lions.
Right?
Yeah.
And this was about people that have had
to deal with these things.
It's not saying that we want all mine's
dead.
No,
I don't know,
but you got to hunt them so they're out
of the ordinary
but live well,
people don't understand.
It's the same thing as with the grizzly
bears when they made lying hunting.
Such a dangerous proposition for people
that do it because you're going to get
ostracized people,
gonna show up at your house and protests
like they did that dentist guy,
they've had a call lions now.
Now they have to hire a hitman to go in
there and shoot all these lines and they
make no money.
So instead of making $50,000
per line,
which helps the community,
helps fund their schools and gives them
money and there's been a lot of articles
written about the,
the lie of conservation when it comes to
lying hunting and how little of it
actually goes to the people,
the community and how much of it
actually goes to the outfitters.
But you know how much of it goes to the
community if you don't have hunters?
Zero,
right?
Zero.
You know,
how much of it goes into community if
these people protest the people that
don't want line,
how much did they put in zero?
Right.
They don't help those people at all.
Most of them just are,
you know,
Hashtag activists or Internet people
that are just posting pictures up on
instagram and facebook and getting
people riled up and starting petitions.
But how much of you actually doing
there?
Are they doing anything?
No.
You gotTa Manage Lions?
Yeah.
Nobody likes to hear that.
But if you want people to live in the
same vicinity as lions,
you have to make sure the lion
population doesn't get too crazy.
Right.
And also they devastate the unused
population.
They devastated.
That's one of the reasons why they had a
column in Zimbabwe.
You know,
there,
there's not,
not like they have a bunch of stores
with stock fall me.
So they have cows,
you know,
that's kind of what they have.
They have cows and their domestic
animals that they used for food.
This lions come in and kill a bunch of
those.
So I mean to them a $600 a cow,
that's huge.
You know,
at $600 a cow is,
could be,
I'm not going to say life or death,
but if that gets killed by a lion,
drastically impacts their life.
I think
a lot of people have ideas about
wildlife.
They're shaped by movies and by
television shows and we have this
unrealistic depiction and that this is
not in support or against hunting.
This is just a,
I think,
the reality of humans and our war,
our view of the wild world.
Did you,
you saw that woman last year in,
um,
she was a,
uh,
an editor for game of thrones and she
was in the wild in Africa.
Oh yeah.
You got drug out,
decided to roll down her window to get a
better photo.
And the cat said,
thank you.
He just reached in,
grabbed her,
pulled her out of the car and killed her
in front of everybody.
He drug her out.
That's what a lion does.
Yeah.
Now it's a,
the lions not doing that because she was
antagonizing or because it was hungry
because it's a killing machine.
It's nature's killing machine is the
reason why we're not,
that you don't have to hack your way
through a river of gazelles.
Get your fucking car is because those
cats,
those cats exist.
Well,
it's um,
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm glad.
I'm glad for this forum to talk about
things like this because I know we've
made an impact and because of you and
you reach so many people and you're
wearing an under armour shirt right now
with a big bowl on it and a and a white
bow hunting hat and it's just like,
I feel like there's been education
happening for a few years now and we're
slowly turning the tide and people do
care more about where their food comes
from.
Kind of the process of how my had this
food get to my.
Not everybody's thinking that,
but a lot of people are.
And uh,
it just feels like also like bowhunting
is just a cool thing to be involved.
Shooting a bow is
cool.
Bose awesome.
It's fun,
it's exciting.
And I always tell people,
even if you want to eat plants for the
rest of your life,
you never want to kill an animal,
ever just try archery just for
meditation.
It's an amazing relaxing thing because
to release a perfect girl and have it
hit that bull's eyes so difficult and
involves so many different things that
you have to manage and control that
inducing that it's sort of cleanses your
mind.
Yeah,
I love it.
Oh,
nothing better.
I mean we were,
I post a video yesterday and we were,
you know,
we had success on her act
out.
We have got elk,
so our hunt was done and we were still.
Umi and jed were having a great time
just shooting arrows and having fun.
Shooting at targets and just laughing
and making little bets with each other
and stuff and having a great time.
Do you owe me now you know,
we're,
we're even where he shadowed me 100
bucks,
but I let it slide because under armour
paid for the hunt.
But it's just,
I think what's important about podcasts
and it's not just for hunting.
I think it's important for almost every
really difficult complex and nuanced
subject is you have to discuss all the
aspects of it and you can't do that on a
regular television show.
You can't.
Then you also have to remove a lot of
unrealistic programming that we have in
our head because of anthropomorphism
anthropomorphization of animals,
attaching human characteristics that
we've seen in Disney movies and all of
our lives.
Animals had been.
Our friends have had teddy bears that
are our friends.
Polar bears are selling us Klondike bars
and Coca Cola.
We have all this in our head that these
are these cute,
awesome things which they are awesome.
They are beautiful,
but we don't know what they really are.
We have an unrealistic idea what they
really are.
We might see them in the zoo.
Oh,
there's the bear in the zoo.
High Bear.
This is not what they really are and
unless you have real world experience
and where they really are.
Like I was saying to Tom,
the guy who owns the ranch and tell them
land that was saying,
you get this an amazing place and I
think you should take people on guided
tours that have no intention whatsoever
of hunting.
Just show them the Rut,
wild elk.
It's so much greater than any experience
you'll ever have at the zoo.
With me and Colton and Jameson,
we're out there covered in the bushes
hiding and hearing,
hearing these elk scream all out as were
saying,
this is amazing how many people get to
experience this?
They had these elk had no idea we were
there and we got to creep in on them and
watch them just be wild elk and it was
amazing.
I mean it was thrilling.
It was incredible with.
I mean I'm looking all these cows and
I'm thrilled.
I've no desire to kill them.
I'm looking at elk that I knew I wasn't
gonna kill and I was still enjoying
every second of it.
Like if people could go and experience
that and just be.
I think you would get like one step
closer to an understanding of that this
is this,
this whole world is this wild collection
of things that are interacting with each
other.
Right.
And if you know,
just one piece of it,
you can't really judge.
No.
All of it,
you know.
And so what should they do?
Maybe they should trust people who've
been there,
who've done it,
who understand,
who aren't bloodthirsty killers,
but actually have been out there and
know how it all goes together.
It's okay to trust people like that and
not think that hunting's bad hunters are
bad.
So I'd be like,
maybe I just didn't get it,
but I don't think so.
The hunters had a voice before,
right?
I think before podcast came along,
we relied on people like Rinella or
yourself to write books and then you
have to read those books.
Nobody wants to read a fucking
now and your,
your reach.
So it's a.
what's that saying?
You're preaching to the choir.
So whoever's buying the book.
Exactly.
It's already on your team.
So this has allowed us to reach to
people,
reach people who maybe are on the team.
Yeah.
And that's what we've been able to,
to vet the vet it and discuss in detail
and go through it.
So I dunno,
I mean I just wish people could have
more of an open mind about it.
And,
and it takes time.
It does,
yeah.
It takes time.
But
I've got a lot of messages from people
and I've talked to a lot of people in
real life that have said to me that
they've changed their thoughts on what
hunting is by listening to me talk to
Rinella,
listen to me,
talk to you,
listen to me talk to remy and John
Dudley and all these different people
where you get a sense of like,
oh well these are like really good
people.
These are really.
And these are people that are
experiencing this wild thing and it
gives them like this itch.
Because I can remember before I ever
hunted for years,
I had this weird itch about it where I
had been fishing most of my life.
You know,
I always go fishing,
but I'd never been hunting until 2012,
but before that I always had these
thoughts about it.
Like I'd always sit around and I'd go,
man,
what it was like,
that's got to be the best way to get
meat.
It's got to be the healthiest for you.
And I would buy like,
I would always order,
like if they had venison and a
restaurant,
I'd always order it or you know,
elk or bison or something like that.
I'm like,
wow,
it tastes different.
It tastes.
And that's farm raised bullshit.
You know when you're buying venison and
a store,
you're not getting a wild deer.
You're getting some weird.
Can't sell.
I know you're mostly getting it from New
Zealand in fact,
which is really weird.
You're getting a lot of New Zealand elk.
So when I would think about it for the
longest time I was getting like little
fragments of information from these
television shows and a lot of them were
terrible.
I'd watch a lot of hunting shows and
they would be like real rednecky,
low brow,
really fucking Yoko dumb dumbs.
And I'd be like,
well,
that's,
I don't want to be involved in that.
And then I found Rinella show.
And that was the first thing that opened
my eyes.
Oh,
okay.
All right,
here's a guy who really smart and well
read and cooks all these things and he
cooks all these animals in this really
delicious preparation.
I'm like,
okay,
now I'm intrigued.
And Luckily I got to meet him and
luckily it started me on this,
this,
this journey.
But for most people they're stuck with
that wolverine movie.
They're stuck with that image.
And,
and being involved in this for so long I
can say.
And I,
you know,
I do a lot of different things.
Um,
the ultra running community is not a
hunters.
I mean those are pretty green people and
uh,
but I can say that for me,
the best people I know,
my closest friends and people I can
count on for anything,
like I said,
our hunters and it's like hunters,
I think just have a different
perspective on life or death struggle.
And where that's driven home for me is
the death threats.
I get there's comments right now on,
on a couple of my photos from people
that said,
somebody said they hope I.
I get home and my family gets in a car
crash and I get there just isn't enough
time to where the flames are burning
them and their client that the windows.
That's the kind of stuff people post on
my photos
today because I hunt hunters.
Meanwhile,
is that person eating a cheeseburger
right now?
I don't know.
Just are they?
Are they buying their calf than chicken?
No,
but they're just.
They're weak.
People that don't understand that how
life works.
Hunters understand the preciousness of
life.
We take life to sustain ourself.
We accept that fact,
so we appreciate life.
We appreciate friendship.
We appreciate somebody who's there for
you because you've been down,
you've been up,
you've killed animals.
You know what goes into to eating and
surviving.
Somebody like that puts on the blinders
judges.
People wants my family to die.
They don't even really what they're
doing is just trying to hurt your
feelings,
but hunt,
but that's what I'm saying.
Hunters won't do that.
Hunters are,
I dunno.
I think we can generalize because
there's some hunters that are pieces of
shit,
you know,
it's like I know are hunters,
so you know some of the best hunters.
I'm just.
I think that's when you get to the elite
of anything,
you get to people that have exceptional
character that have allowed them to get
really truly great at any pursuit and
now you're talking about guys like Leila
Kosky or Remy Warren.
You're talking about the elite of the
elite,
right?
If they were doing anything that would
be amazing at it and I think that when
you're talking about the character of
those people,
those are people that have overcome
incredible odds to become very good at
something that's insanely difficult,
which is bow hunting and I think a lot
of these people.
The problem is,
first of all,
there's an anonymous communication on
the Internet.
That's a problem.
The problem is talking to people in
person.
You get social cues.
If I say something mean to you and I see
I hurt your feelings,
you feel it.
You trying to like reach out and hurt
someone.
You're not even in the room.
You're throwing a ball,
you're like closing your eyes and
they're on a bomb over a bridge,
you know you're not,
you're not seeing them.
It's not,
it's not.
It's a bad form of communication for the
human animal because unless you commit
to only being nice and kind or friendly
or or funny online,
unless you commit to doing that and
never trying to like reach out and add
attack someone and hurt someone,
you're using this whole thing wrong
because you're taking advantage of this
weird little loophole that existed in
communication where you can communicate
with someone with no repercussions
because if someone said that in front of
your face,
oh,
they never would though.
Exactly.
But if they did,
you know it would get fucking hot.
Right?
If someone said that to me in front of
my face,
it would be very hard for me to stop
from assaulting them.
It just seems weird that hunters don't
go to to a Vegan.
How do you know if they have pages?
I assume they have pages and just talk
shit.
Tons of them.
Yeah,
but we won't do that.
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's not something they're not doing
anything that we oppose,
right?
Well,
I don't oppose people eating vegetables.
I eat vegetables.
They in their mind that we are doing
something that is immoral or that is on
evolve and I think that's just
ignorance.
They don't understand that we are here
for a very temporary short amount of
time and the more we embrace the
richness and complexity that is life in
the life eats life struggle and the last
we fingerpoint and more.
We try to look at our own footprint,
our carbon footprint and the
sustainability footprint that we live,
that we leave on this world and in my
eyes,
there's no more sustainable way of
living than supporting conservation
through buying tags and supporting it
through buying outdoor equipment,
which what is,
what is the number of percentage of
taxes that go from when you buy hunting
equipment that goes straight to
conservation.
It's like 11 percent I.
something like that.
Yeah.
Which is millions and billions of
dollars.
Like Rocky Mountain elk foundation has a
great bunch of charts that show how much
money each year hunters to contributing
to wildlife conservation.
It's stunning.
It's billions of dollars and it is
number one in conservation by a fucking
long shot.
I mean,
it's the second place is like a tiny
fraction of what hunting contributes to
conservation.
Yeah.
Most people don't know that.
It takes these kinds of conversations
for people to find out.
The hunters know that hunters do know
that his gun and ammo taxes result in
one point,
1 billion for world war for wildlife and
conservation each year.
One point 1 billion that's just gun and
ammo taxes.
Forget about bows and arrows and a
hunting equipment and clothing and all
the different factors that play in
different pieces that contribute to
conservation.
It's an amazing amount and you're not
getting that from people who are
philanthropists.
You're not getting that from people that
just want to be nice and contribute to
animals.
You get a tiny fraction of that.
Yep,
that's true.
And you know that whole thing.
You know,
Rocky Mountain Elk Foundation,
they came up with the hunting is
conservation and it's like a little part
of that though,
when I hunt,
I don't think I'm going to go out here
and conserve,
you know,
I think I want to kill a mature animal
or take me home to my family.
The byproduct of what we do is
conservation and that's where that money
comes in and that's where the hunt
hunters,
you know,
buying the hunting licenses and honey
tags because people have told me,
well,
are,
are you,
you're taking credit for being a
conservationist,
but would you do that if you didn't have
to?
And I'm like,
it doesn't matter my money,
my money is there.
Whether I won,
I would do it or not.
Well
also here's an important thing hunters
chose to,
to,
to vote to put that amount of money
towards conservation.
This is something that nobody fought,
right?
We've never fought,
oh,
that's too expensive or this or that.
No.
11.
Oh,
one over money.
Gladly do it.
Yeah.
And it's.
But it's like,
you know,
I don't,
I'm a hunter first.
I'm a conservationist because I'm a
hunter,
but you're also a hunter because people
before you were conservationists and
they made sure that the hunting was
protected and that you didn't have to be
a conservation is first and then hope
that your kids are.
They're excited.
Could be hunters because the world would
be in more balanced.
We tied them to.
They tied them together and it's,
it's.
This model's worked so well.
It does work so well,
but it's been represented so poorly.
I think up until recently,
people just don't,
haven't understood what.
I didn't understood what Stan,
what it was until I became involved in
it.
Right?
Yeah,
so I'm very thankful for people like you
and people like Steve Rinella.
That opened the door for me,
so and then I feel like as much as I
preach about this,
as much as I'm redundant is fucking
annoying to a lot of people listening.
I think I have a responsibility to share
what I've learned and to communicate
about this.
Even though people get mad at me.
You're stope killing animals.
All caps.
Yeah,
they're really mad.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go stop eating grain.
You fuck it if you,
if you look at the people don't
understand you go.
We've talked about this before.
If you look at a greenfield after it's
been plowed,
what do you see?
Vultures flying over his wit.
Yeah.
Once I combine goes through and gets the
wheat,
I mean there's all sorts of dead animals
of vulture buzzards flying around.
And uh,
I mean even so you drink coffee.
How do you think that the coffee beans
were?
Those are grown.
There's no weeds.
There's no,
you know,
I mean it's just there's animals dying
for your coffee,
get those animals dying for everything.
And I think that the closer we can get
to a real,
true organic relationship with,
with life,
with all life,
plant life,
I mean,
I fucking hate the idea.
Pesticides,
you know,
I hate the idea that we're spraying
things on certain plants to kill them so
that we can grow other plants like large
scale agriculture.
When you look at a giant Cornfield,
ladies and gentleman,
that is one of the most unnatural things
in all of life,
and it is one of the most weirdest
things.
We've just accepted as being natural.
It's not natural and it's one of the
reasons why they have to dump nitrogen
into the soil and all kinds of other
shit and pesticides and use roundup and,
and,
and use giant machines to grind up all
this stuff.
And that's not.
I'm not saying you shouldn't eat wheat,
but I'm saying all of this is unnatural.
Cities are unnatural,
this is unnatural,
and the more we understand about the
true nature of our interactions with
this life that we are,
we are surrounded with the better off
we'll all be.
And it doesn't mean finger pointing or
saying that you should watch your family
die in a fire.
Like that's not helping anybody.
They don't understand this.
It's just,
it's just digging in on both sides.
It's sort of the same thing that people
do in politics.
You know the right hates the left and
the left hates the right.
Nothing gets done because everybody's
just digging in,
supporting their side and it's just,
we all need to realize that this life
that we're experiencing is far more
nuanced and requires far more research
and far more understanding of all the
different pieces that are moving.
That was another great thing about that
hunting trip is I had no idea what,
what,
um,
people were attacking Donald Trump for,
for about a week or anybody we're going
to fight North Korea or didn't know
anything is awesome.
I was just hoping that no one got nuked
and the time that we had no service for
a week,
I was just hoping there wasn't a new
attack or Kim Jong,
uhm,
didn't shoot a rocket over Japan or
wherever the fuck it was.
I didn't know any of that and everything
worked out just fine.
So that was a win win.
And we're here.
Yeah.
Well listen brother,
let's wrap this up.
We just did three hours.
Amazing.
It goes by like that.
That's good.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you for getting me into bow
hunting.
Thanks for taking me on this epic trip.
Uh,
thanks to under armor,
uh,
thanks to uh,
Tom,
the owner of the ranch and everybody
else involved and that's it.
Alright.
Alright fuckers,
that's it.
See you soon.
Bye.
Keep hammering,
hammering pitches.
The.